Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Let me put the man of the hour, the star of the show on the screen.
Oh, I shouldn't start off with that.
No, this is like, we lead up to it.
It's a build-up.
We don't give it right away.
We gotta lead up to it.
Okay, not good morning.
It's 2.30 in the morning.
Hello, everyone.
Yes, I am back with Marvel Rivals at 2.30 in the morning.
You see, I have a perfectly good explanation for this.
I took a nap.
That's really it.
But that's enough explanation for why I'm here today.
That's enough of a reasoning why.
Like it gives enough context.
I took a nap.
And then the thing is I've been wanting to stream rivals for a while because like, you know, like the streamer awards.
So for those who don't know, who aren't tournamentally online, the streamer awards was just announced.
And, you know, like you don't really win anything.
Especially as a VTuber because I can't really go to the event because there's cameras everywhere.
And like, you know, like there would be like, they tell like nominate like these are the people that are nominated and then you know the camera literally fucking zooms in on the person that's nominated so like you know obviously as a vtuber like i don't really get anything out of this other than uh
other than like recognition and like as a content creator that's all we need
honestly recognition and and stroking the ego and that's all i need honestly like i need bragging rights exactly bragging rights exposure i don't even have to win as long as my name is on there i'm like happy for like the rest of the year which is like two months but that's enough for me
another thing to wake up to so um so yes i found out like i like you know this week that um the streamer awards the streamer awards uh just came out for nominations and one of the categories is best marvel rival streamer and obviously you know i'm thinking i don't sometimes i don't even get paid to be like i love marvel rivals like the fact that i uh also fleshy thank you for the rain thank you thank you i hope you had a great stream fleshy i just started my own stream so um and it is two third yes i just started my own stream and it is 2 30 in the morning um but yes uh so i felt you know i was like holy like i want to be there i just want to be nominated i don't i don't i don't think i'll win
because I, I literally, um, promote them, like, for free.
Uh, sometimes, you know, sometimes they throw me a bone or two, or throw me 45,000 currency, but, like, you know, or throw me 45,000 units, but, but, you know, I totally do it for free.
Uh, um, um, but, you know, um, I just signed would be pretty cool to be nominated uh yeah quote unquote for free uh practically for free guys practically for free um um but anyway um but then i realized i don't know if they count my youtube hours because like i don't because like the terms and conditions the fine print was like So in order to be voted in this category,
you gotta stream like a hundred hours of the game that's to be nominated for.
And I don't fucking, you know, I don't fucking really stream on Twitch that much.
I mean, if you look at my broadcast history, um, it's like last time I streamed Marvel Rivals 17 days.
I don't know.
I think it was 17 days ago.
And so it doesn't look very nice.
If I get nominated and then they're like, bitch, this person doesn't even stream Rivals.
you know I feel it'd be weird so I was like okay I gotta make sure I gotta make sure I clock my hours in I think I have enough my manager was like yeah you sort of you have a hundred hours but cuz it's like a hundred hours over the year on it's crazy I I was actually so surprised because my manager was like you do have a hundred hours in this year for Twitch only which I was very surprised by it because I was like oh my god on I don't I barely stream on this platform and yet I somehow still got a hundred hours on Twitch as like for arrivals that's how that's how much I this is how much I know I have a problem the fact that like I do have a hundred hours not even on my main platform
Alright, 99% of my Twitch streams are my maravos.
And, like, okay, this is, like, how I do believe, like, it might not be a lot for, like, I guess, like, you know, in context with pros who have to scrim this game.
Scrim this game every day.
But, like, it's, this is how many hours I've put in.
I'll show you guys how many hours I've put in since the release of this game.
and then because i play off stream i remember like um some uh and some streamers when they see i remember i think it was like moxie and craiggy they saw me on stream like on their own stream while i was playing off stream And they're like, oh my god, she plays off stream Because it's like,
it'd be like 4 in the morning And I bump it to Craigie and Moxie And they'd be like, what the fuck is she doing playing off stream?
I'm just like, I just enjoy the game, I'm sorry I, they're like, why is she streaming it?
I'm like, I'm sorry, I just enjoy the game I can't even fucking play it off stream I have fun off stream, okay?
Like, God forbid, the grind, exactly.
The grind rests for no one.
Why aren't you locked in?
Bro, I do it for the love of the game, exactly.
So, yeah, because like, you know, sometimes I don't want to stream my grind, because sometimes I just play the game and I don't talk.
I literally just go, I literally just here to be a fucking healer like I don't I don't fucking talk to anyone I just go and take my heels you bitch like
um um crap thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you uh uh yeah thank you for the 200 bitties thank you thank you uh yeah so yeah so now I'm awake and now you guys are awake too
small steps i i know i need to fix my sleep schedule but also i want to be nominated for marvel rivals right now because i i that's what i was most worried about i was uh honestly most worried that like i was just look at my twitch and be like that's not enough hours because like it's not my main platform but also because like you know i have to sort of be a variety streamer so because like i don't know i could i would stream i'm sorry but like i will be very up front parent.
If I could, I would stream Marvel Rivals every day.
But because I know my career is very important, and I did tell myself I should not self-sabotage myself.
I'm a variety streamer.
Yeah, we know.
Born to Marvel Rivals, of course, to variety.
I don't have a problem.
No, you guys are so lucky.
You weren't there for my Overwatch and Apex Addiction.
It was just like this, honestly.
It was literally just like this.
But like, the Barth Knights back dead were not so lucky.
I was like, guess what we're having today?
That's right.
More Apex.
Oh, guess what we're having tomorrow.
That's right.
Apex again.
And the next day after that, Apex again!
That's all we're having.
Nothing else.
Oh, you think I'm going to talk to you guys?
No, we're just going to fucking play Apex.
So, yes.
Now, you know, now I'm like, I want to play Rivals.
And then my manager would be like, no, you don't.
And I'm like, what?
Like, that's what Twitch is for, for your, for your little shenanigans.
I'm like, okay.
Like, dear God.
But yes, exclamation point vote.
If, uh, if, uh, I mean, not if, you will nominate, you will nominate me for best Marvel rival streamer.
What other Marvel rival streamer fucking?
advertised Marvel Rivals after concert for free played one game of Rivals right before I had to perform in 3D.
What other Marvel Rival streamers have done that?
That's right.
Me.
Sorry.
So, so anyway, also all the pro players right now are, uh, and all the pro players and all the other streamers are doing the land thing at DreamHack.
So it's just the demon hours are free real estate for me right now.
Just because like, you know, all the other streamers got to do that watch party thing.
So no other rival streamer has a 3D concert.
That's because they're already 3D.
It's just a regular concert.
But even then they didn't do a regular concert.
Um, um but yeah so these hours are actual like like i guess like free low hours now not free low for as in i'm gonna win my games but as in no one else is actually sort of streaming today and for the next week um just because like there is that i don't know you guys know but there's a one million dollar land right now uh uh that's going on that started today and because of that all the streamers all the other the real marvel rival streamers uh not the part-time marvel they don't have to know that there's no way they watch this vibe be like we're gonna not make the part-time anyway um not the part-time marvel rival streamer they uh so uh they all have to do like the watch party uh watch party of the million dollar land um so no one they're not gonna be awake at this time also the pro players are definitely not fucking queuing at this time just because you know they kind of be awake to fucking play in the tournament uh a million dollar tournament by the way so um these games might be
very interesting because i have no idea what to expect because we don't have real players online including me um so so i i so honestly i feel like the entire um and to see like which which team once doesn't want it more like honestly because none of the real players online at this time especially at you know almost three in the morning um yeah so we're like you know we're all the part-timers right now they're queuing at the moment um so yeah we'll see how it goes also i have not yet played the game with the voice changers Because if you guys didn't know,
Rivals added a new update where people can change their voice.
And I actually don't even know where the fuck that settings look.
I'm so, I'm gonna, I'll let you guys know.
I'll let them talk one time before I mute him.
I, I, like, I, I don't care if like some of you guys think it's, it's not funny to me.
Like, it's so, I don't know.
I find it incredibly annoying.
these streams um um but like uh so there's like all these fucking um add new save oh my god you can adjust the fucking oh my god you can create your own voice changer too but uh from what i've heard from stream from other watching other people's streams it's so bad i i don't like like it at all I understand they want to be like because it's like It's like people it's just so annoying the way people use it Because I understand like oh it makes people want to use comms more But they just give us two settings just do a masculine feminine Don't do like don't give a symbiotic row Because like I can't even hear what they're saying Like I would watch the stream and I won't understand what they're saying Because they choose some fucking dumbass setting like What was it the symbiotic or some shit or like the pumpkin model or alien like I what are you saying you might as well not you might as well like fucking uh just go beep bop beep I it's the same thing I don't even know what you're saying
like you might put your mic your microphone next to the microwave that's really it that's all I hear um yeah so so I if anybody uses voice changers on my team I will We can listen to it one time and then I mute them like that.
That's it Do you throw is that why you're called E-O-M-M agent?
I don't throw it's just unlucky
It's just unlucky look rivals is a hobby for me So I just I might be cursed that's really it
anyway let's let's queue up i don't know if anyone would be getting on um i don't i feel like carova is fucking left his pc on at the at the lat i heard the pc's were crashing like apparently the the games were like hella delayed um because there were pauses everywhere um during the land i hope it fix it it gets fixed for tamara but that's what i heard like from um from the broadcast that it there were so many pauses because everyone's pc was crashing and so like it made the land go like super over time um no i didn't try the zombie mode i heard the zombie mode is pretty addicting but also i'm not really a pve person um so i don't know i've never really been a pve type person but i did hear it's very addicting i i find the jeff build really funny though like the and bigger and bigger i find uh i find that one pretty silly um because like when you're playing jeff oh all right sure you invite me because i don't like being party leader i don't like being um like i don't like you know
pressing requeue that's that's really it i hate that responsibility you know just pressing requeue it's so much exactly it's so much work also makes you your open mic i can hear your birds oh you have birds oh my god yeah unless it's in the morning unless it's it must be like super early or something um but yeah i feel like these hours are like the only like this is for you asia
It's, it's, I don't know if it's unlucky, but like, it's mostly rivals during these hours, but this is for you, Asia.
The Asia Goons.
You get to have, thanks, Jokey.
You get to have the Marvel, all the Marvel rival streams.
Finally, and the early morning EUers.
That's for you guys, unfortunately, or fortunately, It's only Marvel Rivals.
But hey.
It's for you guys.
I guess it's time.
Where are my players?
Where are they?
I guess all I have is roleplay.
That's fine.
This is a real game anyway.
Let's see.
Oh.
I bought the pumpkin chest.
Yeah!
Sorry, the devs got me the pumpkin, Jeff.
Yeah, it's so cute though.
Wait, is it this?
This.
I got my own pumpkin.
Yum, yum, yum.
Just in time for Halloween.
Hello everyone!
Jeff is here.
I am here to roleplay.
It's so cute.
I find it so.
I actually...
I like all the Jeff skins.
I think Jeff has like all the best support skins.
Whoa, why are we fighting?
This is a role-playing lobby.
I'm selling a BP.
Your name is...
Whoa.
Hi.
Would you like some candy?
Oh, shit!
I don't think he wants some candy.
It was trick-or-treat, and I don't think I got the treat.
I'm breaking role-play.
play immersion hello where am i hello i'm here oh hey wait wait don't kill me i'm just a little guy i don't remember how to get how do i get out of here oh it's right here i always get lost here it's just all stairs all right hello everyone i am here to roleplay as a fellow jeff hello would you like some candy look at that aren't i a cute one that's right am i cute
it's not for free yes pay up
turkey is being what what you mean pay up i want your love i want monetary value.
Being cute ain't for free.
Oh,
fuck.
Oh, shit.
No.
My god.
He stopped me.
He stopped my grift.
I was about to scam those looters.
He's extortion in my game.
He stopped it.
I was just about to scam them.
How dare they?
The nom.
Whoa!
I don't know why he hates me so much.
What did I do wrong?
I'm just giving everyone a little bite.
Lexi, thank you for a thousand bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for being cute, Doug.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright, guys, don't judge me.
But I don't want...
Guys, don't judge me.
But this is meta.
You don't understand.
It's meta now, okay?
Like, I don't want to get dope.
I...
Don't judge me.
It's...
I'm just a meta slave.
I also want to live.
And I don't want to try that much right now.
It's my first game.
Guys.
Sometimes, you know, you just want to hold left click.
Is that too much to ask for?
No, don't worry.
I fixed it.
I just have to have, like, my YouTube studios tabbed in.
Look, it's the first game.
And, like, this is the hero you play when you don't want to try too much.
apparently dive is like very oppressive now okay dive is very oppressive and you know sometimes i like being alive okay sometimes it's just being alive it's pretty cool our oh she isn't a try all right who can try at three in the morning we all know why we're here at this time
We all know why we're here.
And it's East Coast server.
So these people are playing at like 6 in the morning.
I have an excuse.
I'm on West Coast.
It's still 3 for me.
Some people here are literally living in East Coast right now.
Playing this game at 6 in the morning.
That's going to be me in 3 hours.
But we don't talk about that.
It'll happen when it happens.
Like, I'm playing at 6 in the morning.
That's right.
Yeah, you are.
That's fine.
We don't need a second support.
I'm Rocky Raccoon.
That's part of Joke.
Yeah, that's right.
I have a court order.
That's why I'm playing Rocket.
Look, see, I can get better.
Four, three, two, three.
Oh yeah, no, we are doing it.
So let's support our essence as a joke, but that's alright.
It's what I get at 6 in the morning.
It's really what I get honestly.
Like that's understandable.
I knew what I was getting into.
They can't complain about the heals though.
Like this is all I can do.
See look at that.
It's so easy.
I feel like when you're playing like any other support, you got to be like on for like the All of the games You have to be like 100% aware, but for this one I just do this I can just do this I don't have to be aware I can be like 200.
I'm not winning.
They're running triple support What the fuck?
They have two more supports than me.
We did it.
I don't know how, but we did it.
The brain not required.
That what makes it fun, you're right.
I don't know how, but I take those.
They literally have two more supports than me.
They have triple the healing.
That's right.
I uh how does he get on you have three supports how do you have the same time of all as me that's actually crazy that you the Luna has how much damage were we doing bro I feel like I'm at the end bro what the fuck all the other supports have oh at the same time as me that's actually crazy how I don't know how they were farming this ult.
They should not be farming this ult.
Farming dangerous.
Oh, he fucked up.
It's okay.
I got alt again soon.
It's somehow still working.
Honestly, at this rate, they should actually surrender.
This is sad.
They used all three ults and we still won.
Yeah.
Who would win triple support or one fucking raccoon?
that's just sad i'm sorry that's really sad like this should not be working oh oh don't worry i got you don't worry i still got you i don't know how all right here you go go do your thing there you go Yay!
Technically we have two support alts because we have Captain America.
Yay!
Honestly, I would be very embarrassed on the enemy team.
Maybe this is the new meta.
I would say that and then I'm gonna reverse sweep us.
I know it.
I fucking know it.
That's usually how it goes.
I get too confident and then like, win the second round and then my team's gonna start yelling each other and then i'm gonna lock myself in the room and cry myself to sleep and be like stop please stop fighting mommy and daddy you volunteered to be experimented on is that true he didn't lie all right too real to hear you Is this...
Are you thinking about something else instead?
Like...
Alright.
Yay!
Yeah,
technically we do have two support elves because there's Captain America.
You're right, two Christmases.
Always remember, Jokey.
We can get two Christmases.
I'm just gonna be here.
Like they can't really see me.
I don't know.
Fuck did this guy.
Did the mag die?
What is going on?
Bro, did we just have all the DPS players?
Okay, see now they have- oh now they have Widow.
Yeah, I don't- one of them is definitely very mad.
I'm gonna say now we have Widow.
I think we're fine putting this here.
Oh, that guy's brave that guy's very brave doing that without like any wait where the fuck are they oh okay goodbye oh okay like do we just have all the aimers did you not have one single DPS player they have Lord icon so I assume they do two Christmases and two birthdays this should not be working but I won't complain Oh,
goodbye.
It's okay.
I have a res.
Yeah.
I go.
I go heal from five miles away.
Yay.
My whole tea.
Oh, goodbye.
Never mind.
Oh.
Here you go.
We, oh.
I was gonna say we can live forever.
Somehow we did.
didn't live forever.
I don't understand.
There we go.
Wait, we did it.
Yeah.
Me too.
This is the...
This is the 3am keys.
Where your dreams can become reality.
It shouldn't, but like, nothing makes sense at this time.
Nothing makes sense at Demon Hour.
it's like teams that should never be winning wins yeah i understand i don't oh they now they have one support hey look see they're like look it worked for them they're like look it worked for this us okay maybe it'll also work i don't think he sees me he sees me
okay i was like i don't think sees me and i literally whoa oh that's fine
it's okay see the rest of my team are okay yeah we'll play guys yes oh not not our captain as like i was like has anyone of your team even died yet as i've died uh praeus thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you oh my god i'm zero down how can i do I have bro literally if I heal even if I do one damage someone was gonna die I could feel it one damage and someone was dead there was no way I could actually fucking shoot anyone America never dies poor America the rival games of all time
there was like no time to actually fucking shoot someone All right, back to my favorite part of the video.
I feel like you don't see Venom anymore.
I can't believe it.
Venom made the roleplay.
How...
They don't appreciate the pioneer of the RP servers.
Hello, everyone.
I am here.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, give me a sec.
Now I am here.
Oh, hey.
Wait, where'd everyone go?
Oh, they died.
I'm here to bring joy to the server.
I heard it's someone's birthday!
Oh, shit!
It's two birthdays!
Let's go!
Yeah, you need to pay respect to the kickfringer.
Let's fucking go!
That's all!
I'm a fucking volleyball evo.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, first I did not realize the new meta.
No way.
Yeah, what the fuck is the funnest you're doing?
Don't worry, guys.
Hello, Peter.
I got you.
We can double the fun.
It's what the ladies want, right?
It's magic mic tower with me and Peter.
That's what we're got.
As-to-as.
As God intended.
It's like, you know, God gave you these cheeks.
Of course you gotta use it.
It would be a crime not to.
Cheek-to-cheek ass ass.
Woo!
Let's go!
Don't have to compete with the other Venoms here.
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad that...
That Venoms are such a rare species now in the RP servers.
No one appreciates.
No one remembers the pioneers.
of these servers monopolizing the party let's go don't worry oh i was gonna give punisher a good time
we can't let the history erase us guys which hero do you think you want to be today you don't understand if daredevil comes in I will not play any other support Don't understand Never forget Exactly I'm not gonna banish from this match
Understandable But yeah no The reason why Rocket Raccoon is back in meta Is because this guy exists And also this guy And also And also this guy And also uh this guy and also uh there's more by the way and also this guy and then this guy and um and this guy so and this guy too so the list goes on and they buff like 50 of these guys oh yeah blade whatever blade's still shit he doesn't really matter is altron still bad yeah there's better triple support to play like people just play this this this rocket Luna uh Invis or Mantis if you have triple and Jeff everything but him why Thor because like he got buffed his damage got buff and everything but yeah this is why I don't play Luna anymore because like Luna now you have to be like 24 7 aware of your entire surroundings and like That's not for some reason that's not fun That's just that's just a little bit too much,
you know And like even if you like hit every freeze You know hit every shot you somehow still die so So I rather not deal with that I rather just you know if someone you know what I can do?
Okay, so like when you someone dives you as Luna you hit your freeze, but then like Like, you still, you can sometimes, you might still die because no one peels for you.
But you know what I can do when I get dove?
No cooldowns.
Yeah, that, yep.
I literally just go.
I was like, oh, shit, Venom?
That's all I have to do.
Goodbye.
just I can literally just leave yeah just get that out of the way banana just get that all the way oh no no what whoa oh they have penny I was gonna say like what the fuck was that oh goodbye there double oh my god he's just walking up to us oh they have Emma wait i don't like that all right nice oh they have daredevil and there is a um there may or may not be a pen there's a penny right behind me so i'm just gonna stand here like i don't really want to deal with that what holy shit okay yeah i was not expecting them to have that did like one penny of us like what the fuck all right hey i guess i'll delay we don't even no strange portal oh i think because we used it for the for the fucking other portal
oh well oh that's not fair they have a rocket for the penny too they have even more Well, good luck, because my damage is apparently not enough to break that wall.
That's alright.
You know what?
Fuck this.
Oh, I'll use it later, I guess.
No, fuck it.
Let's go.
You know what?
That's unfortunate.
Oh, that is very unfortunate for our Luna.
I hope our Luna...
Okay, never mind.
Alright.
okay um when i say hope for luna guys i don't think i don't think this is winnable the the game gives us and the game take if it's yeah that's um um our luna was a little oh you know i do that too don't worry luna when i fuck up i swap to another character and be like yeah i fucked up on purpose because i didn't want to play play this support i get it i get it also who the fuck is the punisher farming anyway good luck
i'm leaving her like i'm sorry there's nothing i can do there's actually nothing i can do there we go hey guys Um, our invas is gonna get capped, but that's okay.
Yeah, I just wanted to reset.
I altered on purpose.
Uh, good luck, I believe.
Are they still fighting him?
Holy- oh shit!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god.
Okay, there's a little- I do not like this.
See, that would have been me if I didn't pick rocket guys that could have been me thank god you gotta pick rocket first before you get before you have to go through hell
good luck guys you can fight him i believe there you go look at that not zero damage oh what the is he doing over there Oh, that's a little awkward.
I mean, I could.
Hot alt.
Briggs these up.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Bruce, he has to live.
Oh, okay.
The double support alt.
Um, okay.
That's...
Oh, and then he dies!
Yo, do you guys want to shoot their fucking rocket up?
Can you shoot the voice changer?
Oh my god, that's interesting that our Invis fucking...
Our Invis fucking...
Okay, I don't know why our Invis ulted that, but that's okay.
You know, we all make mistakes here.
Oh, and then we see nine.
Okay, that's okay too.
That's okay.
We all make mistakes, guys.
We all...
Oh my god, is that part of the story?
software no it's a little too high he's gotta uh he needs to he needs to lower the voice a little more that's crazy like we should not i will say i don't know how three people see nine that there was three people there also our invis is so close to the fucking to like everyone Goodbye.
See what I could do?
I could just walk away.
Oh shit, I can't walk away no more.
Oh shit, you blinded me.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
There we go.
My team is very special, but you shouldn't expect anything during demon hours.
I think I'd win more game if I actually play it during real hours.
Like, what's the fun of that, you know?
You know, it's all about the challenge.
Oh my god.
Goodbye.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that was unfortunate for... Oh my god.
Get her!
Not me!
Don't get me!
The invisible woman is right there!
actually getting her bro i have to kill you okay there you go he actually tried to get her but isn't it fun to win you're right but like isn't it fun to win an unwinable game
okay that's fine don't worry i'm doing my best oh don't worry i forgot res is oh my god what how did they see that well i hope my end bro i i there's nothing i could do i could only press one button like this is literally the only thing i can do for my team press like a one button i swear to god the daredevil fucking lived holy shit double actually lived that that's insane oh that's um well i'm trying i really have
i can build them in the bottom part bro what do you see what for me Wait!
My god, there's daredevil.
Bro, someone killed a daredevil!
Holy shit!
And to be fair, I feel like I got like 20 ults over my one invis.
Okay, that's fine.
It's so fine.
I have tried my vis.
to get on point right now all right there we go i can leave point i can't leave point i'm literally the only one on point that's fine it's okay here you go guys i'm here for all of you i'm no longer here for all of you please they fucking how do we keep c9 i don't understand
bro how do we keep seeing not hitting this oh he wasn't even okay you know what that makes sense him not being a supportive player that makes a lot of sense
dude the only time we don't see nine is when i a little fucking rocket um tiny ass rocket stands on a point against six other players, against the enemy team.
That's the only time we don't see nine.
That's crazy.
That's so sad.
I'm just a little guy, and I have to stand on point.
The fact, oh my god.
Oh, wait, no.
I was going to say, how the fuck does he have 10 deaths?
And I was like, oh, wait.
He was on mag.
Is my current rank?
I haven't played much this season, so I'm only in Celestia 3.
I was Celestia 3.
I was Celestia 2 for the last season, and that was, like, top 500, but I was literally, like, three, four games away from...
Oh, not me!
Not me!
Not me, though.
And then I had to fly out of New York.
So I didn't secure top 500.
I didn't play a lot.
this season i've just been like chilling because like this season um this season it's uh supports have it bad if you're not on rocket you might as well like if you're not on rocket you're in hell that's really it and i sometimes you know i i don't want to be in hell
Actually, it pasted me.
Whoa!
I do nothing I can do.
And we lost that.
What?
How do you feel about the meta?
Um, it's not fun for supports, apparently.
This is also why I didn't play this season, because everyone's telling me how it fucking sucks as a support play, like, for support players, because it's like, you know, um, Like, you actually have, you have to be so aware of everything.
You're not playing Jeff or Rocket.
It's like, you can't really do anything.
I mean, you can, but you saw what happened to it.
Now, watch this happen to me.
You see that?
That's going to happen to me, too.
Goodbye.
I feel like this is worse than the last dive we've had, honestly.
This feels worse than the last dive.
Dive meta.
Alright, guys.
Oh, nice.
We have three support.
Oh, except they're out of contact.
I'm just gonna wait here.
Oh, I guess I'll stand here, too.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, no, this is bad.
Okay, let's go.
This is five.
This is real firepower.
It's okay.
I'm right clicking.
That's all I can do.
Oh my god.
You fucking almost died, bro.
There's no way they see this hell, this res, right?
There we go.
Yay, we prolonged our defeat.
Let's go.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Oh shit.
Never mind, we might not win this.
That's okay.
No one's dying, but it's okay.
But we have a good stream!
Oh yeah, no, this is over.
It may or may not be over.
Bro, I'm sorry, bro, you're so fucking.
Oh wait, wait, unless, unless...
Unless!
Oh, never mind, we lost you.
Oh, goodbye!
Bro, I can't, I can't help you, bro.
I can just right click.
Goodbye.
That's all I can do.
The thing is, we don't have, we can't play Jeff because Jeff is banned.
Jeff is, like, the only thing you can do in this situation, unfortunately.
Why do I just put this here?
There's anything there.
There we go.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
We're securing our victory.
We don't need the other support of...
See, if we didn't do two support of us, we wouldn't have won the fight.
It's just, you know, the double security for us.
It was all planned.
all right there we go man if only we had another support that's so unfortunate i guess the plan didn't work as well as i thought it would oh unless unless we got a pick goodbye goodbye holy okay i'm i'm still alive at least oh okay um I leave now.
I don't think our...
Oh, unless...
Unless...
Our Emma still has diamond form.
She's still alive.
But that is still possible.
We're down one.
Our infants is face tanking, but that's okay.
Sometimes you got a face tank as a support.
And now we leave.
We slowly back up.
I swear.
But...
Oh, wait.
No, our daredevil is ace.
I was like, what has our daredevil...
I was gonna say what has our daredevil done but he's ace I don't know how but he did it all right maybe we can do something with this yay oh goodbye we're doing it guys I don't know I slide to myself hello guys hey hey hey hey Invis okay you I hope you die too I okay that was nice to see you from my fellow support That's okay.
Sometimes, it'd be like that.
Sometimes the other support just doesn't know how to turn around.
It's okay.
We go forward, not backwards in life.
In game, in game.
I hope he gets you too.
Oh, there's someone over there.
Oh, there he is.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
I swear to god, I hope he kills you too.
I...
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, there.
Oh, that's not fun, is it?
Oh, it's not fun, but I actually peeled.
Wow, Toxie.
If I see my other support, not helping me when I get tope, I will avoid, I, Redfields avoid me now.
I'll avoid him, too, because he did not turn around.
But, does not turn around.
You know damn well I'm going to bring him to you.
So we'll both fucking suffer.
He has to kill one of us.
And I can climb walls and I know you don't.
I'm sorry.
After what I saw.
I'm not going down alone exactly.
honestly i feel like we actually could have won him out of solo support
we healed together you die first no not die together i literally brought the daredevil to our invas and she was fucked i guess daredevil was like that's an easier target i was like yeah i know
so what does the invas have yeah she has push she has like in this jump but when she had the thing is me climbing a wall has zero cooldown
so i know who he's gonna chase when he didn't support me first i still peeled for him when the third double went after i still shot my heels at him he never even turned around for me i still healed him.
It was not my fault that my heals might not be strong enough for Daredevil.
That's not on me.
That's on Barbell Rivals.
They just gotta these are above rocket again.
Give him like 100 kilos per orb or some shit.
Might as well.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Can't bring me down.
Today's a raccoon day.
What happened to me, guys?
I've changed.
You don't understand, chat.
So many things happened this season.
Did you not see what they did to Invisible Woman?
Did you not see them gang up on her?
If I wasn't Rocket, that could have been me.
I live longer to become what I hate.
Oh, thank God.
Their devil got banned.
Arlo, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Elo hell has changed me.
It has.
I mean, it's called Survival of the Fetis.
And I'm here to survive.
If I was a Luna over there, I'd be lucky to be alive for like 20 seconds.
be like triple digits.
Sorry, I'm thinking about Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
This is surviving if you lose.
Yes, I'd feel better.
I'd feel better knowing that I lost and I only have single digit deaths.
I...
Did you not see how many devs Red Thrill's ad?
He had like fucking 12 or something.
He had like 15.
Thank God I'm not that guy.
He had fucking 15 devs, bro.
I think even more, I'm pretty sure.
Because he started with 10 before we did attack.
Bro, there is no K in...
There's no K in Rocket, bro.
It's like, it's DA.
kills it's it's just da
like rocket rocket killing maybe like one stray bullet just accidentally hits the head oh shit oh wait wait a minute it's okay that's how I won my first game today surely it'll work again all right oh my The worst part is I actually have to play closer so my heels get to them.
Oh, goodbye.
I guess not not fast enough, I guess Bro, I'm fucking catch this Just catch my orb There's nothing I can do.
You just gotta catch it We're just gonna play catch that's literally the only thing I can do Bro, what the fuck?
Why do they give them two some?
Oh my god, please They...
They fucking good.
This is real firepower.
You're ready for action.
All right.
My good.
This fire.
Just ricochet.
There you go.
Did you see that?
Like, did you see that orb fucking bounce back to me and set up to the team?
Simple geometry ain't so simple.
Who would have thought?
It's way too RNG bouncing off the fucking walls.
Oh.
Surely he's not gonna eat me, right?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, I didn't see her.
I should have fucking destroyed it.
Um.
Oh my god, two!
How the fuck did he get two?
I was very surprised.
Good luck.
There's still a chance to stop them.
Hello.
Oh, catch this aura.
Hey guys, are we?
All right.
Look, I did my best.
I'm surprised I survived long enough.
Oh, yeah.
Well, what was the goal with that?
Yeah.
Edgar, shut the fuck up.
Whoa!
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, bro,
Zio, I don't think he's okay.
I think there's, I think there's problems at home.
I think there might be problems at home, guys.
Oh my God, bro.
It's like seven in the morning.
He's out here saying some gamer words.
I'm afraid of what?
Bro, I think there's issues beyond rivals.
I don't think rivals is the right type of therapy, bro.
There you go.
This is real firepower.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
has taken so much damage here.
Oh, hey, we have another support.
I was not expecting that.
I didn't go on the roof.
That's my bad.
But to be fair, I don't think that res would save anyone.
I thought I could throw that roof in the...
I could throw that res on the roof and then like...
And then the roof fucking collapsed.
Like, I don't think it was possible.
Oh.
Holy fuck.
I mean, I could learn Jeff.
At this point, might as well.
I don't think this is winnable.
I think it's learning Jeff hours.
It's okay.
Well, it's not okay, but like, I'm okay.
It's not okay for him, but I'm okay.
Hey, guys, you just want to move up?
Because the point is over there.
I don't understand why we're, like, at our spot.
Hey, do we have...
Where's our Luna?
Oh.
What?
Um, not my fault.
I ulted.
Oh, there you go.
For your crime of double-alting, you get eaten.
I guess.
That's very unfortunate.
Bro, my ult came out like a whole five seconds earlier.
I'm honestly.
My ult literally came out five seconds early.
Don't worry.
Geometry!
Sorry.
Her crystal is very...
Wait, we won that?
That's crazy.
We still don't have a second support up, but hey, it's the little things
He was very armed and dangerous We had to double support up like oh It would have been you know what would have been cool if we had another support up But that's silly right that's so silly
Oh, where the fuck is our sword going?
Yay!
Oh, shit!
Okay, it's fine.
I think they're fine, right?
Yeah.
See, I believe.
That's why I didn't pick Jeff.
I didn't swap to Jeff.
See, that's how much I believe.
Alright, I have my ult now, so...
I would try and give our Luna ult, But also, I...
Well, yep.
Goodbye, Luna.
Unfortunately, our Luna is gone now.
I don't think I need...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we win this.
Yeah, we definitely win this.
Yeah, you gotta stand in front of me because my entire team needs health right now.
Like...
I was gonna say, like, if you want health, stand here.
Stand in my POV.
Alright, I'll try and give our Luna heals.
Alright.
I don't think we need that, but that's okay.
Yummy, yummy.
Yay!
One more foot.
Is this fun to watch?
Bruh.
Who needs skill?
Thrilling gameplay right here.
Technically, I don't even have to move.
Okay, our Luna can actually die from this, so we gotta stack this.
We actually have to stack.
Look at that.
Technically, I don't even have to move if you think about it.
Like...
I just move just for the sake I just I move just because I you know it's just reflex at that point when I play real support play support characters for some reason they just don't know I exist so it take like I could still do heals from here moving is variety moving is a choice Play of the game.
No way.
He's real to me.
But yeah, technically...
I move when I play a real support character.
Yeah, I'm playing tower defense right now.
Quotaw.
quote-blank I could just tape my left was it I don't remember which mouse button the heels at how much I don't care as a rocket oh is it okay right click I could technically grab tape tape my right button right click button down and AFK and Like, go to the bathroom.
Oh, yeah, get, like, what was it called?
No, I play Cookie Clicker, and you get, like, something that, like, just presses the cookies for you.
Yeah, I can get an auto-clicker.
So why do I just get...
Can I get mad for that?
If I get an auto-clicker and just that blind right-click?
Probably.
Yeah, you get...
And bro, on rocket?
Imagine auto-clicking on rocket.
That would be like the day where I was like, I'm ready to beat my addiction.
It's the only way to get me to uninstall.
To get banned.
Oh yeah, no, he's fucking dead, dead.
Bro, what do you want me to do?
If I could, I threw- throw my balls faster!
My god, I already have 90%?
Jesus Christ, my tanks are beaters.
You know what?
Fuck it.
It's God.
I did not think that they could destroy it that fast.
You know, I- guys, I- Oh my god.
Okay, he's going again now.
To be fair, I did get the Bucky all out.
I got the Bucky all out.
Oh, our story is done.
He's done, done.
I would have to report it in.
Like, I, bro, I know, like, life in the...
Maybe, like, life right now, IRL ain't so good right now.
But I don't think rivals the answer.
you might need a touch grasp.
Wait.
There you go.
That's fucking right, Raccoon beats Shark.
Not in real life, but I mean, I'm fucking cool.
Oh, shit!
Alright, someone better stack on that because that can actually kill her now.
Jesus, no!
What the fuck?
I was like, no!
I did not think he'd be up there.
I was not fast enough for that.
Oh my god, wait.
Rixie lived?
Was it my res?
How the fuck was he alive?
Never mind, shark does be raccoon.
Who would have thought?
Shark did be Raccoon.
Yeah, he didn't...
Doesn't say land shark?
That was lie to you.
I was told he was a land shark.
When the fuck did he become an air shark?
I mean, I could technically just heal from here.
Maybe they'll come over.
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Can I...
Can I hit that down here?
Oh, wait, unless Maybe I can actually Simple geometry this or shoot through this Hole.
This might be easier Honestly, this could be easier
Yay What am I ADing for?
Why do I need a Shreve?
Here's the hole That will eventually hit them, I think I think it'll be fine She can build support our...
Oh.
They might be dead, but like...
Who knows?
Oh, see, they're alive!
Well, not him, but...
There you go.
Oh, goodbye.
I mean, almost work.
Maybe she'll...
I'm hoping...
Yeah, I was gonna say, I'm hoping you'll eat her instead of me.
There we go.
I can literally just stay here.
Like I said, what the?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Where did he go?
Why?
How did he get here?
I thought that was my teammate.
That actually...
Oh, was that from the...
Oh my god.
I was like, where the fuck did this guy come from?
I was not expecting that.
Look, it's slowly heading over.
Yeah, what?
How did he hit that?
Oh, he missed.
That's sad.
Oh.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, I go heal this way.
It's fine.
There you go.
They won't know I'm here.
They won't know.
Oh, it's okay.
They're not coming on the other side.
So I can do this.
Oh, don't worry.
I got you.
He's coming over, but I still got you.
Okay, that's strange.
Literally, he came back just to die.
That's so sad.
I mean, I can technically put this here.
Like, I'm doing my best to keep you up right now.
Oh.
just in case just in case just in case just in case
i mean that's fine that's okay i'm still alive see look at that my luna is still alive
yeah i mean this is not the best gameplay to nominate me for marvel rival streamer but like we get what we can get see that duna could have been me guys that could have been me guys i could have been eaten by that jeff and just left to die but instead look at me go no this this is this is real rivals gameplay right there it's not about the crazy place that you can do on dialogue or the 20th freeze.
It's the right clicks.
It's the hardest job in the game.
Alright, I gotta leave.
So I can right click here.
Goodbye, Riggzy.
Oh my god!
I can be here, though.
Now I can be back here.
And I'll be So, oh, it's okay.
You can catch it.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck is he doing there?
You can't get me.
He might have got me.
He might have got me, guys.
What?
Oh, is that supposed to know he was going to get me?
Okay, I might be able to grab all here.
All I have to do is just...
I'm 89.
Just live, just live.
That's all that matters.
Just live.
They didn't live, but that's okay.
Can we...
Oh, goodbye, all.
Bye.
Guys, I think we lost this.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's not fine, but it's okay.
Look, I knew that this was gonna be what was gonna happen.
I had a feeling.
It was sort of pretty obvious.
It was sort of very obvious.
We blame the gamer.
It's it's sort of they gave us a little hope there I sort of have a feeling how this game was gonna go
I try I don't know if I did try that hard I didn't even I'm thinking like how much can I try as rocket like how how much can you actually do I think if I- I don't know if I went through that portal?
I don't know if I would have lived.
Alright.
What is it this guy, right?
Report player.
Voice chat of abuse.
I think, yeah.
Very much hate speech.
I'm gonna use the...
Let me use the bathroom.
We're back, guys.
I'm back.
Okay.
I might play something else that's not rocket and then die 20 times just for you guys so you know the real pain as to why I have to play that character oh my god but we have a penny I'm sorry I lied we have a pen I lied never mind we got a penny When will I ever get a penny?
I get...
We can have three mines.
Why the fuck would they ever been?
Why would they ever been?
Rocket.
Are they gonna...
Are you trolling?
There's no way.
That's fucking stupid.
If they try and ban Rocket.
He has...
He lives...
He gives no impact to this game.
Even if they don't Venheller, it's way easier for me to kill off.
Fuck that.
I don't want to deal with Venom.
I swear to God, if he wins the 20%, he's gotta do the lottery.
Okay, double Venom.
That's fine.
I'd rather not have Venom.
I was like, there's no way this guy wins the double lottery.
There's no fucking way.
okay next game if I don't get a pet next game and then there was never a next game is there donkey next game I'll play an actual real support that teammates bad Luna and strange yeah okay but what season there's no way they would do it for this season
Like, like, people in the lower elos, they ban penny.
And I'm like, why?
People in the lower elos, you ban fucking penny of all characters, because they don't know how to handle penny.
You just don't know what to do against penny.
Which is crazy.
You just turn around and shoot her.
Like, look how big she is.
There's a fucking little girl inside that robot.
You scared of a little girl?
What the?
Where are we?
I was so confused.
Were he TPed?
Why would you TP there?
whatever it's such a weird ass place yeah i'll be the same what the fuck is that tp that was a whoa goodbye oh all right oh they're running name more and they're running name more oh my god our strange is dead by the way there's no way i didn't know it catch this bro this is the best I could do for our strange like literally me fucking Kobe being these orbs oh my god he caught it Kobe catch this all right if we could run triple support we would go mantis and save like make our make our widow actually viable because at this point he's just doing like like key shooter
go here.
Oh, shit.
That's good.
Oh, that is not good for me.
There you go.
Oh, I got it, though.
Infus got rest.
Did they do anything with my luck?
I don't think they did anything with my luck.
I don't think.
I did not see that hot guy.
If I saw that hot guy, I would not have fucking position missile there.
Or it may be like, you know, not You go!
You go, Widow!
Oh shit!
We're winning the fight!
It's fighter time!
We were winning the fight.
Oh!
I mean, I'll be here?
I don't know what's going on, but...
Okay.
Wait, where is my rest?
Okay, it's over there.
All right, see we did it!
It's like a penny versus a penny right now.
It sucks because they're running such an OP comp with Namur Hela.
Namur Hela team up is so fucking OP now.
Hello.
This is where...
Oh!
That's fine.
You'll be fine.
You can handle this.
You're a strong independent woman.
And you also have a cloak with you.
Where are you?
How?
Where did they shoot my res?
Ooh, got hit.
Oh, it's just a widow.
That's fine.
I didn't even know they could hit my res.
That's so shy.
I was like, you can do that?
Oh, goodbye, Penny.
Maybe, maybe don't stand next to the only place the Angela can kill you.
Wait, yeah.
Wait, why the fuck?
Literally, there's no other place that Angela could have fucking killed the penny.
I'll just send her off the ledge.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Oh, goodbye.
There's no way they see this, this res in front of me.
Goodbye.
Oh, hello.
Hello?
Hello!
Alright, don't get Hawkeye!
Alright, I'm gonna keep my...
Actually, I'll let Cloak do her ult first.
Like, I believe...
Alright, I'll put this here.
I believe in our Cloak!
Okay, I...
There's no excuse for a Mac to be there.
I'll just say that.
Um.
Goodbye.
There's no reason for me to hold out of there.
Two of us for no.
Oh.
Alright.
I think our hella might instantly.
Yep.
Goodbye.
Uh, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak.
Okay, okay.
That's cool.
You know, my old...
would not have saved you but that's okay i don't know why i cloaked in and out there this was the perfect time cloak it truly was there was only one time to out there cloak and that was that day that's okay
i get
it it peaked one time one time I wanted to be.
Look, this is the one time you can use your ult.
This is literally the one time.
This is, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's okay, it's okay.
We don't need my ult.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm gonna do it.
Just to kill it.
Oh.
I don't know.
I want her.
Arnold first, but that's okay.
I feel like she should have ulted first, but that's okay.
Oh, there we go.
We got the up.
Because there are so many times when...
Oh, never mind.
She's dead.
Okay.
That's so unfortunate.
Wait, we don't even have a penny.
Why am I this character?
I only did it for her!
Okay.
That is surprising that I live.
Alright.
It's okay.
Oh, wait.
No, she is still Penny.
Wait, did he fuck it up?
Oh, he got snared.
That's okay.
Yeah.
We're doing something.
I think I might need a...
I want to, I'm gonna, it's so risky, but I'm gonna get rid of my res and then shove it into this hole.
Yay, we did it!
Let's go.
The stream rewards have so many categories.
I close it.
You know how, you know what you can do?
Just put Jokey button on all the categories.
Just do that.
the whole circle exactly i don't know okay he lives i was gonna say all right don't worry i've got this watch oh not yet not yet though they're not pushing in the moment they push in oh never mind we have us we have a captain america it's like a it's like a third support I mean,
I could put it...
Oh.
Hey, they're breaking my rocket up.
How come we can't do that on the other side?
Don't worry.
Geometrying right now.
That's so cool.
I wish I know how that feels when we do that for them.
Oh, well.
You think he knows I'm here?
Oh.
Oh shit.
Well, I got you.
I do think we gotta have someone on the point, though.
Now I actually have to move because they have a hot guy.
And I think that he'll, if he sees me standing there, I will most definitely get headshot.
I don't want to risk it.
I could feel the headshot from...
Alright, nice.
No head, no headshot.
No head, unfortunately.
For the Hawkeye.
Hey, you know what would be cool?
If you guys can destroy their rocket alt.
That would be so...
It's pretty neat, though.
Hey, how come their rocket alt is still around, guys?
Okay.
Oh, say goodbye to my rock at all.
How did he destroy it so fast?
Jesus Christ.
Maybe I should start putting it in cover.
That's the tip.
Sound, sound, sound, sound.
That thing got obliterated.
That sucks there's less cover and attack.
So much less cover and attack.
I just had to throw it in there.
It's a hell Mary.
You know, we went pretty far.
I did not expect us to go that far.
Yeah, my five second up.
I got scared too because the Bucky ulted.
And I was like, I just got to throw it in.
I had to throw it in.
I couldn't like...
I couldn't like, you know, do like home decorator.
Be like, hmm, what would be the perfect place?
Where, um...
Uh...
Where, you know, the N18 can't see it.
Literally Bucky Olsen.
I was like, I gotta put it down now!
Cap 2 home decorator!
I was like, hmm, do you think if I put it here, the feng shui would be better, guys?
Yeah, I can't think about the feng shui.
Unfortunately.
Yeah.
Oh, why?
Oh, I shouldn't have healed that.
I should have just chilled
They're different for the new penny skin, are they?
Oh, yeah I was paying attention.
They are, look Oh my god, it's like, oh, that's so Oh, shit, oh shit, I hear something I was like, I can't Oh, I hear the Angelo Good shot
Don't worry, I'll hit the wall.
I don't want to peek the Hawkeye.
I'm a little scared.
I'm just going to use the wall.
And just geometry this shit.
I don't know.
The Hawkeye sort of scares me a little.
Because if you're still playing Hawkeye in this meta, he's not afraid.
He's not scared.
Look at that angle.
I know.
Shit!
There's ammo above us.
Yeah.
Oh,
goodbye Strange.
It's okay.
I have res.
Oh.
I'm not dead.
No, you're back.
It's like you never died.
Look at that.
Heroes never die.
Goodbye, Penny.
Oh, hello, Penny.
Oh, Strange!
Oh my god, Strange.
Oh, I got the wa- Oh, see, this is why I don't keep.
How the fuck?
I'm 68%.
Who is he healing?
Who the fuck is letting him farm damage?
Man, I need to do 50p, Mr. Stange.
Um, he's still being resed right now, so good luck, everyone.
Why can I confess?
Um...
Why did...
why did no one touch guys that's so awkward you know what we could have had one person touch it one is one oh yeah no you know bro how the fuck does this racket like who the fuck was you know what like who is he farming that's what i want to know who the fuck was that guy farming there you go there's no way they can break it now that's fucking right look at that that's some feng shui shit right here i leave and then
okay that that's what you know i got feng shui
He's dead.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
And somebody promised, well, I'm just chilling!
I'm not grinding for anything!
I'm just having fun!
And also I want to be nominated for my rival streamer.
Huge fun story for that.
guys i think like all my hours literally of raccoon i have more hours of raccoon this season and the entirety of all the other seasons i played rocking raccoon which is crazy to think about hey there's a hello right behind us but like oh wait oh and there's that guy too oh and there's him too Hey Luna,
you want to save our strange?
I guess not.
It's cool.
Fuck that guy, I guess.
We don't care about him.
I get that.
Oh fuck her.
Oh, she doesn't care about her stuff, too.
This is why I don't peek.
To be fair, she was sort of stuck there, which is understandable.
She watch this.
Feng Shui, bitch.
I leave.
There we go.
That's fine.
I have this.
I don't want to be a part of the problem.
I don't want to be like, is the Hawkeye's 20th kill?
Headshot?
Oh, they're dead.
No, they're- Oh my god!
Why me!
Oh shit, her, never mind.
That's okay.
Um, sure, I'll be on the point.
Who cares about my life?
I'm just a little raccoon.
There's no harm.
Yeah, exactly.
It's just chilling.
They hit a checkpoint.
Now might be a good time to stop them.
You know what I think might be...
I don't...
I think maybe Widows just isn't it, maybe.
But what do I know?
I'm just a raccoon.
What do I know?
I'm just a silly raccoon.
But that's just a little... It's just a game theory.
It's just...
It's just a theory.
No, theories are meant to be tested.
What is this match?
We have a Widow One Trick with Penny One Tricks.
I'm just a silly...
Little guy.
Oh, hey, we won that fight.
How about support us?
Let's go.
You just gotta test the theory out.
See, there's also...
Why do I have to play Raccoon?
Because I don't have to look at my team to heal my team.
I know, isn't that fucking wild?
That should be illegal.
Like...
Like, as a support player, I feel like maybe you should be...
to look but i don't have to i literally just i could look at a wall and i still heal someone might flank you stop speaking like that okay never mind i think it's gonna i don't think this is feng shui though i don't think i got the feng shui on that nope nope had a feeling i had a feeling we're not feng shuiing that
I mean, to be fair, our tanks were, like, so far apart from each other.
I don't know.
Our Emma already has all again?
Who's feeding him?
Holy shit.
I'm sorry, the Emma.
Oh, my God.
Bro, who the fuck is feeding this Emma?
Like, who?
Oh, my God.
This Scarlet Witch is just playing Scarlet, just a DM.
He has contributed nothing to the team, and he still is.
There was no...
Yeah, there was not.
I had to just chuck it in there.
We were all getting picked.
Yay!
No, I...
I had a feeling this was...
I don't know.
They just...
I just think the widow we just needed a mantis but we just didn't have a mantis we just need a triple support but there was no way like if my team was dying so fast with uh with rocket luna my team was not gonna survive with luna mantis there was no way like it was literally like just been fucking uh we have just been like rodon oh yeah the emma with the 60k yeah yeah he was yeah i don't yeah wait that's not fair what the fuck how did their rocket get old so fucking fast when my emma was eating 60k worth the damage that's like crazy where was he bro my entire team was being farmed and damaged like holy oh my god 14k how are you allowed oh how you you live longer than my luna
that's insane oh i guess because like my luna kept getting headshot by the hawk eye though to be fair okay now next game we play we play a natural support character and like die just like my luna there i won't play luna play invis invis is less uh you can try less and still do the same thing as luna
you can try jeff i'm not great at jeff i only started learning jeff last season i just don't know how to alt him use his all efficiently i need to learn better rocket alt placements and uh how to to play this character when he goes I just don't know.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to.
I thought I was in the rank for some reason.
Hello.
You wouldn't hit.
I didn't even fucking defend myself.
Hello?
You wouldn't hit someone that can't defend themselves.
Oh, wait.
No, he would, absolutely.
No, he had eight kills.
He was terrorizing the RIP lobbies.
Also, like, to be fair, when I play on this time, I just don't think they shoot the rocket up.
Because, like, it's 4 in the morning.
Why are y'all...
How do you have the attention span to shoot the rocket up together?
Holy fuck.
Why have my team worked together to shoot the rocket up?
That's crazy.
They have the attention span for that.
I'm sad I am not level 60 at 9 anymore all right I'm not the type who fades play invisible woman it's no longer right click simulator like how is your mind that active at this time I'm the I'm the last support player in demon hours apparently I feel like everyone else like is forced to flex and I'm like I'll play support I'm a support mate everyone and it's just me the last one standing in D-Gen hours
alright what else are they banning the last one standing
because the other support players have regular lives They love themselves more.
Do I get a personal...
If we lose, I blacklist you.
If we...
Right heroes could make all the difference.
That's fucky, right?
So you better... Oh wait, I was gonna say you better play support, but that's our Emma player.
The last support coming to us in a near you.
That's crazy.
That's right.
He's got...
He's like, oh, fuck, I'll play support.
Great shit.
But we need Emma, bro.
Round one.
Look, now he'll try.
Now he'll have to try.
See, when...
See, threatening people is not good.
Unless...
Unless you can win.
Unless, yeah, unless it works.
We just don't have an Emma now, which is...
Oh, wait, we could like...
why the we're running namor why don't we oh my god i hope like the cloak is healing yeah okay that's good
i'm just gonna pocket them real quick that's fine i dropped down so goodbye namor i dropped down to accident because i got
that's fine i don't need it yet Yeah, I don't have to worry about healing because I have the orb.
See, I actually have to try.
Oh, oh, I jumped when I didn't expect him to jump there.
Oh guys, it's like I can aim.
I just choose not to because there's too much work.
I can't believe.
Like I even have load already.
There we go.
That's fine.
Why aim when I can win by not aiming?
Oh, nice.
Yeah, he can look first.
I just chill.
Come on, do it.
Unless you're a pussy.
Yeah, don't be a fucking pussy.
He's gonna die.
Oh, no, he's alive.
Good for him.
We're fine.
I know that Groot has oh, so I'm just gonna There you go, and then I just jump away Where am I?
Okay, I got healed now though Because that magic the magic can technically one-shot so like I got scared I didn't want to get one shot Because it is possible Wait, what the fuck we're doing?
Where did he go?
Um, oh shit!
That's fine.
I don't want to waste my, uh, in this thing.
Jesus.
Oh, goodbye.
Sorry, bro.
Nothing I could do.
That's fine.
See, we're fine.
Um, we lost our only tank, but we're fine.
Oh, I...
Oh my god.
That fucking Groot Wall saved them.
I need to make sure I have my shield.
Because they are running that.
Oh my god, that was so scary.
And that too.
That's the scary part.
Because I have to make sure I have my...
Jesus!
Oh my god, I lost my peel!
I lost my peel.
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh, haha, where am I?
I have to pass the heal, but where am I?
Okay, there we go.
Oh shit, why did you- Why did you get out of the orb?
That's so sad.
I was so close to all two.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god.
The namer got out of his thing, and it like fucked with me.
Alright.
yeah even in your alt the magic can one shot you that's why i don't want to be near my own alt when i'm when i hear magical i have to like basically alt it like very far away it's dumb but like that's how broken magic is oh my god i'm worried about getting headshot here so i'm just gonna oh oh all right That's unlucky.
I can't remember.
Are you...
Jesus.
Why are you still here?
Bro, okay.
Oh, I missed that.
That's unlucky.
I mean, I think we can kill him.
Technically, yeah, we can.
If he doesn't...
Nope, never mind.
He had...
He's a hero.
America.
Don't want to be too close.
Why are we widow?
It's widow hours at these hours.
Oh, here you go.
I'm okay that I'm here.
I don't want to stand in front of the hot guy because we technically have one shield.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I can't.
My damage is not strong enough.
I'm sorry.
My damage is so weak against the Groot shield.
There we go.
See, moving isn't a choice.
I have to keep moving, unfortunately.
If I don't look at him, he can't headshot me.
That's not true, but, like, it's called co-op.
That's what...
Oh my god!
Emma, you know he has his accrued, bro!
He's so dead.
If our Daredevil lives, I...
Oh my god, he's on...
He's on life support.
There's no way.
This is...
He's literally on life support right now.
I was gonna say, there's no way he lives that.
Okay.
Bro, please.
Please, Emma.
Emma, please.
Oh, Mac!
Emma!
Oh, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
These walls are actually crazy.
These walls are so bad for us.
Oh my god.
We just keep getting walled off.
And then our...
Our...
Our Emma keeps getting walled off for no reason.
There's nothing we could do.
Oh wait, we've swapped support players.
Alright, maybe this time.
We swapped support players.
Maybe we got this.
Maybe it is possible.
Maybe this guy won't get walled off.
Oh, we got the widow, the random widow Scarlet player.
Why don't we get the fucking...
Hawkeye player.
How do we get the Skylip?
The Widow player.
Oh, that's fine.
Holy shit.
This building made my frame drop so much.
Alright.
Last fight.
I mean, I have all for my last fight.
Here we go.
This one.
Hope he doesn't actually see me Oh shit, oh shit That was scary
We kill that one dude So yeah, I have a push for this one moment My push didn't work Oh my god, he fucking ate him
He actually ate the fucking matching all the time That's so sad.
Behold!
Behold what, bro?
That's so sad.
That was actually so fucking sad.
The stream swap back to take.
He was like, oh shit.
I'm gonna actually get blacklisted.
I could lie and be like, hey...
Uh...
Hey, hey, if we win this, just give me, just give me your name, and then...
And then you'll get like special treatment From the maid cafe and then he gives... oh wait, but he's watching the stream But then like if he gives me the name and then we lose I know what name the blacklist
I know
what name that's evil hey if he wins he gets a special shout out at the maid cafe if he lose we know what your name
jesus christ he's taking he's taking so much bro briggs he is actually struggling fighting for his life right now with the dps we have
like micro manage bro this like i have to like micro manage my shield so much this is the hard part about invis i feel like because you gotta make sure you don't waste your shield with dumb
all right that's fine oh like so i can have the shield for that
about micromanaging and then also like my ammo shit see now i have shield for this guys look at that okay and he's look at that easy see that's what the shield's for he got grabbed we live oh shit that's a hot guy all right i should technically let our Luna heal,
but fuck that shit.
I'm gaming.
Bro is playing like his life depended on it.
I didn't want our fucking widow to get one shot there.
See, now I don't have the shield for it.
Yeah.
I'm a little scared only because...
There we go.
That's fucking right.
Get in here.
You thought you could leave this fight?
You never, you can never leave.
Our Luna is passively charging.
To be fair, if I was a real player, I would, like, I would swap with her so she can build her Luna up if I was a real person.
But I'm not, I'm anime.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
We're five.
Oh, we are not five.
Luna, why didn't you charge her all?
Luna, if only you charged your all.
Why did you let me push up, Luna?
We could have had her, we could have had her, Luna.
Never my fault.
Not my problem.
This is on her.
Oh shit, nice.
They double support all did.
That's what I like to see.
Oh fuck, I should not have hit her.
The one with the cast is like...
What did I do, huh?
She should have fucking said something.
How is that my fault?
She didn't say anything.
Yeah, I have to like reload too.
Like she has a mic!
She has free will!
It's never my fault.
It's never the streamer's fault.
That's why we stream.
No, yeah, exactly.
Why didn't she comment?
She could have been like, in this swap with me.
That's on her.
Vortex field!
All right.
All right, we have...
We do have Luna out here.
That's right, get back in the fight!
Oh, nice, we win.
Let's go!
It might have been, like, overkill.
I know, thank you for the red.
Thank you, thank you!
We had a good stream!
Yeah!
Cafe, here I come.
See, guys, sometimes it's okay to threaten someone.
In-game, because it was in-game.
In-game, in-game.
Because it works.
If it works, sometimes it's okay.
Look, I wouldn't, wouldn't, he tried.
He tried at 4 in the morning.
If it works, he tried.
Might as well.
Here we see the benefits of threatening people in game.
Look at that.
Plus 22.
Sometimes it just works.
Oh yeah.
Please feel free to nominate.
Not sorry.
I'm booking.
It is 4 in the morning.
But yeah.
Please feel free to nominate.
nominate me for best Marvel Rival streamer because I am definitely a role model to all players out there.
I am definitely the role model to represent all of you in this category.
And after seeing you throw in that man, I would definitely nominate.
Honestly, that is peak Marvel Rival's behavior, though, guys.
You can't lie.
If anything, that is that is what you should expect.
when you when you meet a Marvel rivals player like if anything I'm just not seeing gamer words if anything I'm not as authentic because I'm not seeing any gamer words yeah a win or a hold this match I'm surprised it's surprising like How well that actually...
How many times that has actually worked in the lobby?
Hello, Angela.
Would you like a little dance?
Whoa!
That's wrong!
Guys, I don't think she wants this dance.
Hello, everyone.
Would you like a little dance?
Okay, apparently...
Apparently they don't.
Jesus.
Mantis has returned.
No, I 100% believe that the Marvel Rivals player base is very toxic.
No.
It's pretty bad.
It's not as bad as League.
Not as bad as League.
Because like, that's surprising.
It's surprising that League is the most toxic game in the world and they don't even have voice chat i think that's the craziest part they don't need voice chat to be toxic and the fact that like every fucking word is filtered in that game
text exactly text is enough to convey
we learned some some interesting like
because i asked in the previous stream for those who didn't know I Look I did I played my invisible one invisible woman game I told you I will play like a real character and I did and we won Like I can't play real characters Um But for those who didn't know Um I asked my chat what is like some of the most creative things They've read in a leak chat Um when they're feeling extra spicy That day Um I think I think my favorite one jump that's all that's it just jump
they can't ban you for that what if you're telling them to jump to this lane you know like oh jump to lane a you know yeah jump
also keep yourself safe that one's good whoever invented that you know they They had a really rough game.
I feel like Keep Yourself Safe was inspired by a really fucked up game.
It was so bad that they had to invent the best insult I've ever heard.
I learned that from League.
I don't play League.
Not like my friends who plays league taught me that.
But sometimes we take stuff other people are guarding.
A former friend got banned for the acronym and was dumb enough to message support and say, I'm from Alabama and that sound that means kiss your sister.
That's why you say the full thing.
It's your sister.
Why was I bad?
Four, three, two, one.
You need to stop that vehicle in its tracks.
Oh, no.
It's Spider-Man.
Wait, can we even do, um, can we even do, like, Animal Crossing comp?
For those who don't know what Animal Crossing comp is, literally, Jeff and Rocket.
But they asked, oh, wait, we do have Animal Crossing.
Let's go!
That's Spider-Man.
Spider-Man ain't doing anything now.
If our venom dies, like, no God can save him.
Like, he was meant to die in this world.
Because you're...
The amount of...
Oh!
Goodbye.
No, now our venom will definitely die.
Okay, I just need them to know that, like, I am doing everything I can to heal them.
Oh, my God.
They're full fucking dive.
That is terrible.
That is absolutely terrible.
They're actually, oh my god.
That is not fun.
Never mind.
See, this is not fun for our Luna, that's for sure.
I just have to play, like, more...
More, like...
What's the word?
I have to play more, like, all over the place, like, the climb.
Whoa.
Hello, Jeff.
I am here for you.
Don't worry.
Whoops.
I mean, I'm trying to keep my Luna alive.
There's nothing I can do.
There was literally nothing I can do.
That sucks.
This is rough.
They're running full fucking bad.
They're only missing like venom, honestly.
I don't even know we...
Aww, goodbye.
I don't know.
I think the only way to win this is if our team turns around.
And unfortunately, my team, other than me and my support, we have yet to turn around.
So that is very unfortunate.
Like, it's really we gotta do one thing.
Goodbye.
Oh shit.
I told you.
They're all just like crazy.
What do I do?
What can you do?
Bro, I literally, I was in the middle of our Luna ult, but fuck me, I guess.
That's why I fucking, I hate...
Yeah, no, I hate the magic of...
Because literally it can one-shot any support of, like, as you guys saw.
As you guys saw.
There you go.
Maybe our Bucky will turn around.
Oh, goodbye.
That's all we need.
Um...
I think our Angela can live for all of us, right?
Yeah.
We're solo tank Angela, but this is a little hard.
Oh, nice.
Nice up.
All right.
Let's hope that does something.
My ult's going to die here, but that's okay.
What?
I didn't...
It killed through the...
Oh, shit.
It killed through the invisible.
They're out of here.
grabbed me there was nothing I could do there was something we could do I mean it's like at the door so it's not like the most ideal placement but it definitely is not very ideal for me because I Can't really do anything right now.
But I can't shoot him in.
Oh my god, what is he doing here?
What the fuck is he doing over there?
Oh, I'm not gonna make it easy.
Guys, this does not look ideal.
This looks very rough.
Can you go tank?
This range.
I'm touching.
Oh, we're not TPing.
Oh, okay.
I mean, he touched it.
Very unfortunate.
I did not expect him to fucking show up.
I found one of our critics.
Armor patch here!
Um...
Hmm...
You see, I am very limited on what I can do.
Very unfortunately that He's fucking still Oh my god Where's the Spider-Man?
You fucking freak Why are you there?
You goddamn freak Oh hey I'm back Hello I mean it was nice for them to Oh my god Oh my god Goodbye What are they all doing?
I go from one way there's enemies wherever I go there's nowhere I can live they actually they're everywhere they're everywhere they're double agents everywhere and they're actually there like where do I go
He's gonna destroy us, so you do something before he does.
There's like nothing else.
Do something before he kills it.
There we go.
I don't think he sees me.
He doesn't see me.
We just gotta live two more fights.
Everywhere you go, I see them.
I gotta put this out of here.
I swear to God, the Spider-Man, fucking I swear to God.
There's like nowhere I can put my res.
I know that me putting my res there, it's just gonna get destroyed by the spam.
He's just gonna be, like, right behind you.
Goodbye, Strange.
Unless...
Oh, no, he fucked up.
He went through the wrong hole.
Goodbye, Strange.
It's okay, I have a res.
I think he makes it.
Yeah, he does.
Oh, yeah, no, he has all.
Hey, guys.
Okay.
Hey guys
I'm the reload that's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay
Everything's fine Jesus Christ.
Okay, that's on our strange.
That's actually on our strange Nice, uh, I think See, this is why I have to play this guy.
I've got one rocket.
Hey guys, there's like players in front of us.
Oh, fuck, bro.
Get this guy out of here.
Oh, no, no, I know.
I know Spider-Man as well.
I'm fucking leaving.
Nice, good job.
the current score is zero two but uh it somehow worked i don't know how i don't know we'll push all the way to the end but like the effort is appreciated you'll need a top-notch team to win this one how the hell did they not it's because this um this map's last point is like fucking purgatory it's like it's like overwatch had no Murah last point that's basically how fucked up the last point is you just it's like it's hard to push through that because it's so defense-sided unless you like unless you steamroll steamroll from first second and third point like that's really it oh shit subscribe to me
do you truly love do you truly love me then I'll do it after the game I'll do it after the game it's implied by color see it works gas lighting works this man has up financial domination success that's our hoshi that's me oh see it works i mean it gives this man a sub bro he knows it's me and he's like we gotta win Guys,
we gotta win!
Can't embarrass myself in front of her!
I'm gonna call for the life of me!
Now I'm just out here playing Rocket.
Yeah.
Oh, they TP'd?
But they TP'd so far away from us.
That's crazy.
Wait, I love it!
Bye, Luna.
I got solid.
It's okay.
I mean, it's not okay for her, but it's okay for me.
What?
Oh, does he get that?
I just threw that out.
No, he does not.
I literally just threw that out, too.
That sucks for him.
Oh, wait, that's crazy.
That's good.
That's insane, chat.
Goodbye.
Never mind.
That sucks.
That would have been such a good.
Oh.
Oh, goodbye.
Yeah, I don't think...
I don't think...
Oh, wait!
He got it!
There we go.
Oh.
Catch the orb!
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
Hey, guys.
There's a strange up there.
Like...
Just one guy.
Maybe he'll gain from me.
Oh, okay, I thought he'll kill the I I legitimately thought that he would kill My team would kill the others before they kill me, but that's okay That's silly of me to think that
Don't worry, I got the res Are we still pushing who the fuck is one spider-man?
Bro fucking kill a pig Peter Parker, we've done it before.
We can do it again.
He's died, like, how many times?
Get that Spider-Man.
So, thank you for Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
We can do it again.
We'll make sure every multiverse of Peter Parker dies.
But just Peter Parker, the others can live.
I want to use my aura here but oh wait like right here I had a feeling goodbye everyone unless ha ha ha we lost my rocket alt though we lost two how did we lose two oh gosh shit i mean he wasted it all like it was they already won the fight every peter must die like do we really need peter parker we literally have like 20 other like two like there's a multiverse for a reason if anything gwen stacy is a better peter parker than peter parker that's right i said it
Alright.
You take that back!
Okay, that's just false.
Okay, but she is the hotter, hotter Peter Parker.
Yeah, preach.
Peter is hot.
I said hotter!
I am ready to put on a show.
That's all so false.
They're stuck.
Holy, yep.
That'll waste it.
The worst thing said on Twitch ever.
All right, what makes Peter hotter than Gwen?
Gwen's Peter part, Gwen's Spider-Man.
No, no, please enlighten me.
Give me the pros and cons.
This has to be written.
No, I'm talking about like, like it's broke this also yes Gwen is also richer than Peter Parker you think about it he's literally me he's your self-insert how can I self-insert myself if Peter Parker's dead you're so right
I'm gonna get one shot in that all it does oh I'm absolutely gonna get one shot in that all that's not fair it's not fair
I heard the rocket on it.
I was like, there's no living.
You can't live.
Live with that.
I'm only this.
All right, it's fine.
Watch this.
I threw it incorrectly.
I threw it too far.
They don't need to know that.
I threw by... Okay, it's fine.
We won the fight.
It doesn't matter.
I might have thrown that ult.
wildly but like it worked in the end okay and I have res too okay we lost a tank but it's okay I still have res okay we lost you Jesus Christ just fuck me Yaka's all right it's okay
all right it's okay I may or may not have thrown that by randomly chucking my all on the ground.
That was not the smartest thing I've done today.
At least I didn't do what he did.
Okay, yeah, this is not a winnable fight.
Oh, shit!
Look, I am doing my best.
Okay, we're...
Wait, we're up.
We're technically up.
One.
Jesus Christ.
I'm gonna have a look.
And we gotta up this.
I'm gonna up this right now.
The moment I get my luck.
Alright, let's go.
I'm hoping.
There we go.
We won.
We used... where else?
But we have support up.
I leave.
Get the magic open.
I don't want to be in there.
Oh my god.
Oh my yeah, I was not living that.
It's okay.
Our Luna's back.
Oh my god, she is not okay though.
It's okay.
I chucked it.
That's gonna get to somebody, right?
Oh, no.
Oh, no Got someone
How's that magic out there?
I go 50.
Yeah Unfortunately the magic was allowed to do that
It's okay.
As long as he subs, it's like, I'm sitting.
Prove you're sorry right now.
Give me two minutes.
Blacklisted, bro, I think, I don't think you can travel to the...
Minus one potential.
That guy with the public bathroom.
Mike Summer.
Thank you for 100 videos.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Now, yeah.
There we go.
I take those.
All right.
Pay to repent.
Don't worry.
I take repentance super chats or donations.
I'll be right back.
I gotta use the bathroom.
I'm like those.
Those churches.
I was.
forget what they're called what are they called those tv churches tv churches what are they called again evangelist yeah i'm like those television evangelist you're like you send in like you send in a hundred dollar check to be for uh to be forgiven uh yeah pay to be forgiven and then uh pay your way to heaven exactly that's crazy actually that's crazy they're like those those pastors are like fucking millionaires too where's the most famous one like the okay tele on his list of notable television all right you where is united states who is the most who is the court most current most famous i want to look at their website television
Evangelist Who's the most famous one?
Joel Austin Alright, who are you?
Joel Austin, I want to look at your website Lion Pro It's like he's on This looks like a fucking talk show host Like Talking with God What the fuck?
Bro, he has a stadium?
Holy shit!
It's an entire stadium!
my god bro i feel like this is like a talk show yeah look at this i'm gonna download this yeah he has a stadium he is so immensely wealthy i think i chose the wrong career path guys bro he might as well twitch stream too i mean he's like thank you for your donate up thank you for the sub.
He should do a sub-a-thon.
Look at that.
That's crazy.
Like...
Bro, imagine if he did a sub-a-thon.
That's actually insane.
What does this website look like?
Let's see.
Dwell, he has a Twitter?
How many followers?
9.9 million?
Dwell...
fuck bro
okay that's insane the fact there's enough people that know how to use the internet to follow this guy because i would assume majority of his fans are like above 50 so i'm like that's like that's insane that he has enough people at that age range that know how to use twitter and
oh my god let's get it bro let's get it to 10 million guys who does he follow he follows oh he follows the other like tv and jealous this people yeah that's crazy that's like a network like he's gonna collab oh so he could do the collabs with them too like pasture collabs I can talk about this because what he's doing is like It's not blasted me what I'm talking about because what he's doing is worse than what I'm saying
The pasture like literally follows on He literally follows the other pastures who do this shit
That's fucking insane Oh my god I'm a GM knobby what do you get from okay so i want to know like what do you get out of this like together we can you can do a monthly donation yes i want to become the champion of hope monthly partner if you donate uh if if you subscribe to me you too can become the champion of hope monthly partner guys you can be the duchess of hope exactly the dragoon of hope food and medical care provided to 20 over 100 000 decisions for christ at what the fuck is what what decisions what do you do for christ every year 100 000 decisions for quite christ annually what decisions what do you decide for god oh there's a prayer well shouts of praise I don't know what the fuck champion of hope is I have handed and this was made literally yesterday I have handed like this comment I've handed over and surrender my burdens to Jesus and these things are getting resolved maybe not in a way expect but better Jesus wants us to be free leave your troubles I need to donate to
Wait, sign in.
Oh my god, I can write something right now.
Guys, do not, guys, for legal reasons, do not raid this man's website.
It's just, I'm just being silly.
Do not raid the guy's, I'm reading his fucking, like, I guess, supporter wall.
No, like, I'm, like, it just says sign in.
So I was like, what can I?
Must be like, I bet you it's like, it doesn't...
Oh yeah, I bet you this doesn't even like go through instantly.
They have like...
Because I feel like so many people control on these forums.
Um, on the prayer wall.
Uh...
I feel like...
So I feel like they have like actual mods to...
Um...
They have mods to like screen the commons.
like it's pre-screen do not raid this mad site I don't want to get in trouble I don't want to get in trouble he has 9.9 million people following him
he has 9.9 million I'm scared of that that's like more that's like an entire country right there
I am worried about the fucking mad oh goodbye daredevil I am worried about that mad No, because I don't really have Um
I turned I turned around for one second Like we ain't living that Oh Where the fuck did this I fucking went out of Invis just for him
The worst part Is we don't have a mag to kill them So We can take them I don't think we can take them.
I don't think we can take them.
Bro, like, we are sort of fucking blocked here.
This is very unfortunate.
No one's available.
I'm a support.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, he died so fast.
Hey guys, I'm a little worried.
All right, we can finally hide back.
I had to...
I think I actually might have to play Rocket.
I just figured, like, you know, I played a lot of Rocket.
I just think he...
I don't think he could clap hard.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm not surprised.
They buffed...
They buffed the...
I knew...
Oh, it's bad idea.
Bro, like, we clapped at everything.
Yeah, I think my shield had to be closer.
Maybe.
Maybe my shield was just a little bit closer.
Just a little bit.
Nice.
There we go.
Maybe he'll up first.
You know?
Oh, we did not need.
that that's for sure i mean that guy particular though yeah fuck him no worries i've got your back force first yeah we definitely did not need i'm a little worried here because we do have a widow and a magic and like anything that can like fuck me up oh there it is he's gonna use this all first right where was he going where was he going where was he going i'm i'm legitimately so i i'm so confused like he was he was really just traveling around the world with that all i'm like like,
okay.
I don't know where he was going.
Dang.
I was so confused.
Where is our tank?
Wait, where is our Emma?
Also.
Oh, he died so late.
Come on, we just got... Okay, let's...
Alright, let's hope I... I'm... I'm blinded.
Aw, it's because he used this, it's aww.
It's the amplifier.
The amplifier actually, fuck this.
The amplifier actually saved them.
Um, I had no jump and also, like, there was no jump and also I got blinded.
So I was just fucking hoping my shield.
Alright, it's time.
I'm done.
We're gonna die from siloed up, but I'm done.
I'm not dealing with this.
This is the only way I can live.
I think most likely our Luna will die to siloed up.
Unless we all somehow stack together.
Oh, it's okay.
I have res.
It's like nothing bad happened to our Emma.
He gets the restart.
Oh.
think we're winning.
Oh, unless Rigsie just kills everyone!
Let's go!
We delay our death for another year.
Yippee!
Rigsie delays the inevil for us.
Let's go.
Yippee!
Until... And then there... And then their...
And then their sidewalk's gonna ult us and then and then we all die it's like a repeat oh what what if i just i had a few why did i do no run okay here you go oh that's fine that's fine um okay
i okay now we have no No support, though.
Um, um, I don't know.
I think it's weird that our Luna ran away.
But, what can I do?
There's nothing I can do.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
But it's okay.
Oh, we don't have a tank now.
It's okay.
Rixie can do this.
He can win.
He is our tank.
if we give enough heals on him he's practically a tank see look at that he's a oh he's technically a tank at that point we gotta give him enough heals you can technically have 700 hp and we never stop healing him all right so the other guys swap the tanks i think we we definitely needed the mags the entire time because they had a fucking uh i don't like how we're all grouped here like it only takes one it takes one fucking uh widow ult or or uh silo ult but like that widow is just for some reason looking at me i don't know why
the is our way like the fuck is he doing what the fuck was that widow doing like crazy man Man, that bro is crazy.
Or even is my res.
Are they gonna TP?
They should.
There's no way they see this res like right in front of all of us, right?
Actually, maybe I should.
Maybe it'd be better if I don't just put it in the open.
Oh, nice.
Oh, they cancel the TP.
Current score is Zero Two Die Widow I know it's insane Time to switch I like how they typed it right out We're like Yeah no shit There's no TP No fucking a raccoon They need a top notch team To win this one No fucking shit bro Now we win I don't know It's better to not have hope So things can surprise us Oh,
she cancelled it?
Okay, but did she really though?
Or is she lying?
I could easily be like, no, I cancelled it.
Look, I try to play Invis.
It's so strange to be back.
It just wasn't worth it.
It's just...
Why play Invis when I can do the same thing with less effort?
4, 3, 2, 1.
Alright, here you go.
Also, we have, like, the thing is, we have one tank, so Invis doesn't do fucking If we had like two tanks, Invis would be better just for the fact that building alts would be a lot easier too.
And like, I can't play cloak.
Oh, I technically I can play cloak.
Whoa!
But then I can't do like the heals efficiently against.
I'm not gonna try it, cloak.
But I feel like that's just rocket with...
That's just technically rocket with hands.
nice
yeah i feel like cloak is just like another another rocket i guess can do damage jesus christ i wasn't paying attention another one yes holy shit rixie's living in there by one hp he's alive good for him he's actually i have to avoid this widow he is like not contributing to society and they're gonna kill me isn't he
all right nice
whoa what the how is this widow still bro is he gonna kill our support holy why is he allowed to do that that's very unfortunate honestly I didn't think they just let it just let her walk up to her support That's very unfortunate.
All right Me first Okay, maybe If we stack I live if we stack I live do not stand on that point
Oh, wait, he killed my oh nice.
It was just close enough.
Don't worry, I got you.
There you go.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
I was DPSing.
Don't you hate it?
I should have used that earlier.
Alright, that's fine.
I can just say...
Oh!
What is he gonna do?
Follow me?
Burr.
Oh, we're down, too.
Yeah, they res too, so we're technically down one.
Oh, shit.
That's not good.
Bye, everyone.
I'm gonna break my...
Oh, they broke my res.
Oh, wait.
Our Punisher got res.
I didn't even realize my Punisher got res.
Those guys are about to shoot at us.
Thank you.
I know the most exciting support player- that support character you can play.
Truly is so exciting.
I haven't- I was gonna try and play like- I mean the only other character you can play for this man- this- or against them is literally- I guess it's just- because like Scylok- Jesus Christ Scylok is- Are you fucking kidding me?
I don't know, I'm sorry.
Bro, at least kill him.
At least kill him.
Please.
Please, for the love of God, just kill the fucking widow.
He's barely alive.
Okay, there you go.
Nice.
We can passively push the coin, I guess.
There's no...
Oh, now they went mad when I wanted to play.
Look, okay.
That's cool.
Yeah, there's no other support I can play.
If we had two tanks, I'd play Invis.
Don't worry.
The hero is here.
And they don't even have Phoenix.
I can do this.
Alright, guys.
Oh, I mean, I could combo with our Punisher.
Yay!
Why are you out of my...
That's fine.
We have...
Hey guys, hey guys, hey guys, hey guys, hey guys.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I don't know what's up with our Luna.
Walking 80 miles ahead.
Bro, there's like five people behind us.
Yeah, I wasn't gonna...
They killed us without...
I'm not getting all engaged with my...
It's like the only thing we could do.
My Luna, it likes really...
Fuck.
I mean, it almost has up.
Jesus.
The thing is, he doesn't have Mantis Boost, so he can't really one-shot us.
But like, that's like the one thing we can look forward to.
Alright.
There we go.
We walk up.
But where's the others?
Wait, he got away?
You ain't getting away here.
Oh my god!
Hello, can we kill that little guy?
Nice.
Alright, there's three of us on cart.
Yay!
Go, Rigsie!
Go!
Let me put that rest here.
We did it!
Final score!
Three, two, two!
Yay!
We...
Wow, it's like...
Our siloed player seems to be a top...
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
Bro, I just realized if...
Um...
30 PS kills combined together...
Basically equals to Riggzy's kills.
That's crazy.
that's crazy we add like both dps kills to get on the enemy team our coolest one even like final hits is more than the enemy team yay i don't drink today not today satan no drinking today
hey uh thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you all right let me look up I want to know.
Like, what do I get out of donating to this man?
I mean, clearly, like, he gets more than what I give.
Like, I'm not connected to...
But shouts of praise.
Wait, what's the difference between prayer wall and shouts of praise?
Praying for the supernatural?
Excuse me?
Oh, turn around.
Okay, I was going to say it.
Why the fuck are you going to pray for the supernatural?
Okay.
never mind he's once like he's going through some shit a champion of hope let's see joel i want to become a champion hope um what do you get with your help we'll continue to tell the world about god's unconditional love and unending hope found in a relation you can tell that for free with god's help you can discover the champion but i can do that for free
That's why I put in the prayer wall.
Yes, you can.
Exclusive encouragement resources.
Wait, okay.
I must be able to Google that.
Someone must have uploaded Joel's exclusive encouragement resources.
There's no way he DMCA's that.
Exclusive resources.
versus Joel Austin.
There must be like, you must be able to like pirate that shit, right?
bro, that's members only.
Don't leak members.
Bro, someone must have leaked the members.
The members documents.
There's no way I'll grab a must have cracked Pirating Jesus What's that Jesus?
This fucking champion of hope
Alright I want to know what the exclusive encouragement resources is Have trouble giving Click here to give Or call Oh I guess when you call them You like You like You're like You want me to give Please give us your credit card information That's insane.
He has his whole entire He has an entire stadium built for this Bro he can run a Joel con
There is like a dating website for pastures only Wait is that yeah Past dating webs There's like dating websites for crazy shit There's one for like Disney adults And more There's one for like ChristianCafe.com.
It's an authentic way to connect with many single prospects all in one.
When singles like yourself are seeking an authentic pastures dating site.
And will connect with thousands of other singles.
Pastures.
Seeking a pasture dating site?
Not having much luck connecting with the right people.
Are you ready to connect with your healthmate?
ChristianCafe.com.
It's an authentic way to connect with single...
Oh my God.
We're one of the few pastures dating sites online that's authentically Christian-owned and operated.
Most of the...
We're real Christians, man.
Oh, Jesus.
Don't...
Okay, don't be fooled by the other companies.
They're hiding and misleading the fact that they're not Christians.
Some of them are connected to the adult industry.
Rest assured that we are true believers who have Christ as the center of business and daily lives.
Oh, yeah, there's the farmers.
The farmers one I can understand.
the farmers one oh my god they won best customer service in 2013 on newsweek america's best customer service holy shit what kind of cost customer service yeah get a pasture near you
oh yeah i wasn't hit i know there's like there's like farmers one too the the disney adult one is crazy because you have to pay I've watched a video about it because someone was like what is the Disney adult dating website and then you have to pay like an insane um yeah I know best customer service on a faster dating site
and then someone was like what is it like it's like you have to pay like a fucking subscription or some
yeah pick your hero it doesn't come yeah if i'm paying a subscription fee for a disney adult dating site i better get my disney plus i'm not the type who i better get disney plus with that
i think it's crazy that they're like um the other ones are ran by adult sites like because it's That's what adults do.
Alright.
If I'm solo support, I have to play rock.
Okay, there you go.
I was gonna say.
If I have to solo support.
I know farmers.
I know about the farmers one.
Farmers only.
There's some weird ass sites out there.
Because I understand.
Because you're like.
Because it's like who wants to date a farmer.
You know?
You're in the middle of nowhere.
Um, work is very hard.
Uh, internet, you can't get fiber internet at a farm.
Three, two, one.
Like, that's the thing.
I'm just like, because I'm just thinking, like, who would...
Hard, and it's very hard work.
And I'd rather just play rivals.
And I'd rather play rivals and get farmed.
Oh, I accidentally used push.
I was just spamming my left click.
That's unlucky.
That's very unlucky.
I could have actually, like, pulled them, too.
Okay.
Alright, I don't have...
That's fine.
Bye.
Yay!
Oh, I didn't pull them.
Unlucky.
Oh.
Wait, what did it?
Who?
Oh my god, he's solo.
That's unlucky.
He was actually solo.
I don't know who he even ate.
All right, I hope our rocket helps first.
Who's that guy?
Oh, that's our strange.
I was going to say, who the fuck is over there?
I was trying to push him.
Oh, I daredevil.
Alright.
I hope our rocky elves first.
Oh my god, don't keep it.
Oh my god, oh my god.
My one rule.
That guy better turn it off.
I had one.
One rule.
Fuck it.
Oh.
JK.
I should have trusted my rocket.
It's okay.
We're so confident.
We just want to give them a chance, you know?
We just want to give them a chance, guys.
We know we're gonna win.
That's why we double support all of it.
guys we're so confident is it oh that's unlucky man if only we had another support uh not my fault it's not that's it i know it's the first technically
all right let's all the cues in the world yeah see Now we have...
We have silo.
It'll be fine.
Rage bait blade.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I don't know about him though.
All right.
I'm a little...
Okay.
I'm a little worried because I'm like...
where's my team is like all over the place okay now my rocket now my rocket are gonna play chicken because we're like oh who's gonna uh i don't know where oh my god it sucks okay i think it i'm dead i'm still dead
there you go we don't kill him okay i'll gonna say i'll be so sad there you go i have up for this there you go i booted him into our daredevil how to rest it thank you that's 600 buddies thank you thank you um i want to say i'm proud of deception to improve yourself keep up thank you i'll do my best i'm doing my best i mean to be fair i'm playing rivals at 5 30 in the morning but i gotta keep my hours up for the nomination I'm worried they're gonna look at my Twitch channel and they see PUBG sponsor and also the the cube And then it'll be like Marvel rivals 17 days ago It's like got a little worried Like I don't think this person is a rival streamer Now they can't say that I streamed rivals Yeah I'm doing my one week of camping painting look someone has said look everyone else is doing the ignite watch party okay someone has to someone has to be there for the demon hours I'm here for the demon hours it's free real estate everyone else is awake at real times now all right oh oh that's
good there you go fuck that one guy in particular I gotta cast this guys I got a pack I got a cap that I can't fucking heal you like this okay ricksy here you that's scary someone has to get keep this this time slot it's gonna be me
all right that's the 17 days of gatekeeping oh goodbye bro goodbye plastic trees get out of here get out of here Well, you gotta get over here Oh, I don't like this Oh my god, where's my rocket Bro, my rocket is in Fucking Naga right now Holy fuck, I'm scared Oh my god I'm not living this Oh my god My strange god Fucking deleted
Bro My Strange was not gonna be alive.
That's unfortunate for him.
Not even... not even Joel can save this man.
You would, you're right, both of the allies reacted, guys.
Like what the fuck?
Who the fuck was he trying to look?
Oh, I'm trying to heal you guys.
What you guys got?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Well, too bad for him, I guess.
I'm just gonna cap one.
Oh my god!
I didn't realize...
Bro, what the fuck?
What is he doing here?
When?
Oh, and when did he fucking play enough to have up?
Why did no one cap the point?
We had three...
No, no, no, no.
We had three down.
It wasn't even aiming at me, and it's just doing it.
Like, like, legit, like...
Wait, what?
Bro.
I fucking hate the voice change.
I hate that.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
We should have res, right?
We do.
All right, I'll rock it.
As long as...
Alright.
Oh my god.
Please.
There you go.
I dodge everything.
I have up too.
Which is good.
Alright.
What?
My radar is over here.
Alright.
What the fuck?
How did they get over this?
There's a TP for that?
Bro, I didn't even know that.
Alright.
They have two fights.
All right, it's time to play chicken with my rocket again.
Who's gonna break first?
What the fuck?
Me or him?
My rocket, you know you want all first.
You know you want to.
We'll play the point.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Please We're playing chicken so high Oh no It's just okay I like how We've none of both of us did an Alton You were like no you Wait did they ask me to Alton first Oh you And they must be like Why the fuck is this bitch not Alton I'll be like that's how i much i believe in this that was this key was it like bro what the you know i don't read we're just firing we're that confident no you chain is real avoid avoid what if who was he on oh that's that's who is he playing oh yeah i know that guy was pretty bad No.
I mean, to be fair, let's get a win.
Fucking Mr. Pent- I feel like I should avoid the guy that played Mr. Pentast.
Like, I feel like doomer, true.
Or just like, no, you, no.
You should avoid all freeze.
Avoid both of them, but you're true.
Right, you're right.
Avoid both.
No.
wait has he been went no i should i want red throws in there i've never had i've never won a game with red throws in the entirety since season zero i've won zero games with red throws it's just not meant to be at that point heaven emperor all right next examine your let's add analyze you well you're an Adam player how I mean to be fair like I to be fair like you can be an Adam was okay at first until they broke his legs oh I don't have to restart the queue but it's fine I like the I like the gamble I don't think it's weird when you're running triple support I guess but Take him out in the back.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
I have a lot of work messages.
I can't give me a sec.
Alright.
I looked at it and I was like, oh, shit.
That's work stuff.
I'll do that later.
After I degen a little bit more.
I'll do it.
Oh, shit.
It's been three hours.
Fuck.
I don't know.
It's just...
There's just something about Marvel Rivals.
There's just something about it.
It does not feel like three hours.
Honestly.
Like I said, if I wasn't a variety streamer, I would play this game all the time.
I would stream this game all the time.
But I care.
That's how much I care about you guys.
Anything in the zombie mode?
One more than got a job.
Alright.
I mean...
I'll do like one more after he leaves.
That's how much...
See?
That's how much I care.
The thing just streamed only one...
Yeah, but then I get like too tired.
If I just keep...
If I just like stream Rivals on the side all the time.
Because I can only do it when I'm not as tired.
What do I have?
One may feel empathy for an enemy.
I haven't tried the zombie mode yet because I'm not PVE-er.
I know it's really fun, though.
I know everyone's telling me how fun it is, but I just...
I personally just don't play PVE.
I just fight...
I personally just think it's boring, like, when I play PVE.
I just want to fight other real people.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Alright.
I'll give you another Envis.
You know what?
I'll give you a Luna game.
But if I swear to God, if I see one Venom player on the enemy team, I'm out.
It's Rocket Tap.
Yeah, I feel a little daring today.
And Luna gameplay in my Rocket stream?
If I see one Venom, Luna's about to become a furry.
Because Luna's gonna fucking grow a tail.
If I see one venom.
The band venom.
Alright,
we don't... Alright.
I guess I can play Luna.
Alright.
it has been made.
The enemy banned venom.
They were so they were too scared of my rocket.
They heard my thread.
We're like, we can't put her on rocket, guys.
Bro, we can't do that, bro.
Alright.
Um.
They'll be coming in 30 seconds.
Stay strong.
Nah, Torch is like, uh...
Torch is like not that great anymore.
That's why no one bans Torch.
Aw.
Alright, if we lose, we blacklist him.
The deal doesn't stop after a game.
What the fuck?
Who doesn't go outside the door right away?
Fucking freak, who waits?
is open freaks oh yeah if that guy hits me one more time I'd be fun honestly and damage more all right actually have to do like 200% when I play Luna there's no like right here like there's no way the thing about Luna now is that you have to focus more so on damage too because your damage is fucking insane oh goodbye our damage is just too good now but like you have to heal less I should have used that clap I should have saved it for emergencies like right now oh that That is definitely an emergency.
That is definitely an emergency.
Oh!
Wow, guys.
If only I had to clap.
Oopsie.
Oh my god.
That's very unfortunate for him.
Um, if he peeks me, I can heal.
You know what?
Fuck that, I guess.
Oh, I guess I'll walk up.
How do I walk up?
I got jokes left.
It's okay.
They didn't need me anyway.
I was like, guys?
Emma said no.
She's like, you're not walking anytime soon.
We're going to fucking break your legs.
I was like, okay.
She knows I don't have insurance.
What do I do?
She's slowly walking up to me.
That's the scary part.
When they just walk up to you and you know you can't do anything.
And there's nothing you can do of about it.
I always say clap.
I need to, like, I sometimes, my one thing that, like, I always fuck up with is that I use clap way too.
Jesus, okay.
He's gonna wait now.
Oh, nice.
Oh, should have used it.
What?
Oh, put me back in the orb.
Bro!
I'm like, how is he still alive?
Alright.
I got a little too scary.
He says, um, strange of...
I'm gonna slowly walk away from the strange of that they're planning on using.
Alright.
I saved him.
Alright, I'm gonna try and give our cloak up charge because, uh...
They most like, oh, that rocket's smart.
You mean you mean you shouldn't.
What?
You mean you don't just chuck it in the middle?
That's crazy.
Look at that.
I'm just saying.
Yay.
You mean you're not supposed to chuck your rocket in the middle of everyone?
What a wild concept.
A smart rocket player?
Not in my lobby.
Not at 6 in the morning.
Boom, boom.
Alright, here we go again.
See, look, I can win on Luna.
And before they foothold me, it's most likely gonna happen.
Um...
Wait, now that Rigsie's gone, who the fuck is gonna be my...
My 6k, uh, SILOC player?
Oh no, it's over.
Who else is gonna fucking kill four people at SILOC before the fight even...
begins oh oh thought he was actually gonna play another tank all right here we go Jesus that Phoenix got so much all charged from that oh if I got that freeze That would have been sick as fuck.
Don't worry, I got you.
Get that mutant!
I'll push the cart.
I'll let him get all the charge.
I'll just be, uh...
I'll just be cart bitch.
Yeah, surely.
Most likely I'll just get it on the enemy team.
Okay, if you're not gonna push the cart, just go up.
Why the fuck are you so far away from the team?
You're not even close to the cart.
Oh, yeah, no, it's over.
Might be a little creepy, though.
What?
Alright.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
That's very unfortunate.
Whatever.
I'm wasting that.
I don't care.
Oh, my God.
That Spider-Man was one!
Oh, he was one.
him.
See?
It was not a waste of a clap.
I got the spot, man.
Holy shit, he has up.
There is a sidewalk right behind me, and that's what's scaring me.
It's okay.
I have a clap.
Clap, clap, clap.
Yay!
Easy.
It's because they banned Venom.
Thank fucking God.
Toki X made made art.
You don't even have to try that hard to find that.
That's just a given.
Okay, Toki.
I have to do a job now.
GG's.
GGs.
All right, we'll do one more game.
True.
I bet one is being uploaded right now.
Just go to Rule 34.
Alright.
One last game for the ride.
Unless someone else wants to join in.
Alright.
Evil is a rejection of life.
Thus I am a guardian again.
Hello fellow role players.
Oh, that's the new Hulk skin, right?
The old, the last remaining, uh, the last remaining Hulk, like, per human on Earth or some shit?
We gotta give him a show then.
I mean, he has nothing for him.
And he's just like, what the fuck are you?
yeah he's the last hulk on earth he's the last person on earth guys we gotta give him something like
he has he exactly it's been so long oh my lord he's so very lonely whoops That's right.
There is a hook right there.
Look at him.
There is exactly.
There is a guy.
Bro, after this, when he gets sent back to his world, when he gets sent back to his world, he's gonna have nothing.
I'm doing him a favor.
Look how happy he is.
This is why we wake up in the morning, guys.
This is his make-a-wish.
It's his make-a-wish right here.
I think it was for the bitties that you never ever interacted with, Craig.
Oh my god.
Let this man have joy in his life.
I am a I am like I'm practically like what's the word doing the world an entire favor right now oh shit I need assistance here don't worry I got you're jealous right don't worry bro oh he's like he's like begun which beyond women oh wait oh he has preferences
Oh, he's like, he's like, be gone.
Like, I'm practically, what's that word where you're doing that?
I'm practically, like, doing a good deed right now.
Look, there's a shark.
Hello, little guy.
Hey Oh Want a ball
Be gone Thought
All I'm saying Is that not to throw But if you win Your blacklist is from the cap
I'm not saying to throw But
But if the NM team somehow wins, that would be so unfortunate for him.
So unfortunate.
Play support.
Play support right now.
that's right you're a support player now
rocket also you have to be rocket if i i could be really fucked up and be like play play adam play adam no i think the team will actually flame him if he plays that okay stream snipers like that's fucking cool i hope now now you have to play adam Why else would you ban Iron Fist?
Now you have to play Iron, like, Adam now.
Why else would Daredevil...
Why else would Iron Fist get banned as well?
I was going to be like, you can play Rocket.
But now, now you got to play Adam.
Oh.
My team is full of melee.
Look at these other guys.
Yeah, my team is full of melee.
It's not looking so high right now.
You could have stopped it.
You could have been the 20% that stopped it.
They're like, who is he talking to?
Because I haven't said anything.
And so they're like, who the fuck his heavenly father talked to this guy the heavenly emperor is gonna have schizo.
No one has said anything to him and he's having a conversation with himself.
And like he's schizo.
They think he's crazy.
I don't know because no one has said a single word.
They're like, what the fuck?
Oh wow, they have a fucking course they have a silo.
Wait,
he is on Adam!
Okay, okay, okay, that's a joke.
Don't go Adam.
They might think we're actually throwing.
Go rocket.
You might actually get reported.
Bro said, we're joking.
I shall go Adam.
Bro is loyal.
Yeah, I don't want to get in trouble, guys.
Oh, I should have been, like, stay at him until the first point, and then he gets...
No, no, no, no.
I mean, yeah, I was gonna say, I think I could have got this man bad.
Oh, shit, we got two there.
Nice.
Okay, now you can go rocket.
We rocketing here.
Yeah, he is willing.
He is loyal.
Wait, we're on triple support.
Oh, he nerfs.
I don't want to...
I want to be like, get accepted.
Be like, look at...
Don't keep right up using her fan base to win Eel.
Like, like, Celestio 3.
Oh, shit.
Oh shit, goodbye Jeff.
That's unfortunate for him.
Oh shit.
We're okay, we're okay for now.
Oh this is...
I don't know.
Where's my group?
What the fuck?
Was the instructions unclear?
I heard group up and they're like just you though.
Okay.
I like ran into the other because of it.
Like where did everyone go?
Were the instructions really that unclear?
The group of one.
How could I be the only one that grouped up?
Are Jeff is alive?
Go Jeff, go.
Oh my god!
Hey guys!
I'm scared.
Sorry bro, I had to kill him.
Alright.
I think our blade would have definitely lived.
For sure.
Oh.
Nope.
That's unlucky.
I even put it in the corner!
Oh, it's because there was a goddamn Namor behind us.
That's unlucky.
Oh, that's unlucky.
There was a Namor right.
I was gonna say, how the fuck did my ult get destroyed so fast?
He has ult, by the way.
Like, look at him.
He's like, he, what if I just, uh, right now?
Oh, she.
No, Bobo, no more?
It will never know.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
You'll never know.
Bro, what do you want me to do?
I'm fucking, I'm just shooting my gun.
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
I literally just got here.
Bro, I don't have...
I don't have anything.
There's just a portal in front of us.
Is this Winnebill?
Let's fucking find out.
Oh my god, okay.
And then our Jeff fucking dies.
Yeah, but you also got like...
Oh...
We have no healers.
I'm fucking sorry, I was crawling.
crawl.
Sorry, buddy.
Goodbye, Jeff.
At least where I...
Oh, that...
Oh, okay.
I don't want to deal with the name.
What the fuck?
Get me out of here!
It's okay.
Are you taking the heals?
Yay They still have siloed alt which is very scary like it's working I have to reload Okay, I'm here now Oh my god, please get me out of here
I'm doing everything I can And by everything I'm right clicking so hard I was fine, but thank you he's dead like nobody's stacking in that oh okay go magic go okay he did go he did go the
all last yeah there was no way time to switch things up including which side you're on
It was cool.
We had it for one second.
Is that a rocket ship?
Is this someone getting banned at the maid cafe?
Is this...
That's fucking right.
Bro, she looks so scared.
it's so dark he's like he's like talking to the voices like they're like who the fuck is he talking to do you know how to counter a football they're just like bro what the fuck who is he talking he's talking to the voices right now yeah
he looks actually insane
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
All right, we have mag at least, you know.
That works.
Is there just a battle of the siloed players, honestly?
Animal Crossing time.
Oh my god, we actually have like, um, we actually...
Don't worry.
I feel so safe up here.
Look at me, go.
Don't worry, I have res.
Look at us.
Yo, we don't have two res's though.
That's the unlucky part.
Jesus Christ.
What?
Group up!
Bro, good luck with that.
Whoa!
I'm alive!
Look at that, that one second of that all being alive.
We're portaling.
Now you're gonna explain it.
Bro, I don't know what's going on.
Watch me start!
all right that's fine we're so healthy we don't have res but that's okay we we use the res for bait we use the res as bait for the other silo that's crazy that the uh
they were able to build up that fast though guys i don't have res i used it as bait it was like Might not been the smartest thing I've done, but...
Jesus Christ, I hope we have portal!
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta hope that they touch the...
That we saw, but...
Alright, guys, I don't think we're...
Oh, we're not...
We're not portaling!
Oh!
Very unlucky.
Oh, did the magic get rizz?
I thought, like, the siloed destroyed our rizz there.
I have a feeling that our silo might be getting dived.
Just a maybe.
My turn.
Guys, can you guys not shoot my...
Oh, it's not cool.
Not cool.
guys that's not oh my god what the fuck i don't have res dude for that magic use use that res oh my god it's free real estate for this cloak because we don't have a fucking mag that's the worst part this cloak can actually play cloak in 2025 season four that's insane
they don't have any support though we can have a free silo yippee
i stacked because i was told to stack
Never trust my team.
I literally, they're like, Group up, group up.
I was like, okay, guys.
Okay.
I'll group up.
That's what good team player should do, right?
Good soldiers, listen to the winners.
Bro, there is like I refuse to...
No one has the alt now!
That's fucking right!
Yes, which alt lived?
The one in the open, not your stupid-ass corner alt!
That's fucking right!
The alt that was in the open somehow fucking survived.
Oh my god, that's bad.
Final score!
One, two, two!
You have to be shooting...
Okay, I'll do one more.
Yeah, my alt out is in the open.
Some house did not die.
He is.
That's right.
I don't...
You know what to do for forgiveness.
I'm waiting.
Yeah, it's time...
It's him that we're talking.
I told you
There's no way he plays DPS he has to be feeling Alright, what does he actually play?
Wait, who was What was he shit talking?
This guy?
Mewage?
Bro Insula.
He did.
I mean, he wasn't doing bad on Blade.
I say as I go.
aura thank you for the videos thank you thank you oh my god is that the uh my rival streamer the year joekeeper playing was absolutely not her addiction marvel rivals right we actually gotta know all right what is this rank what is this guy's rank yeah vote for me nominate me for marvel rival streamer of the yeah i would really appreciate it guys i you know how much i love oh my god wait that's his peak oh wait he's gm3 right now i was gonna say there's no way this is the first time he's through oh yeah no oh oh yeah you're out of here buddy you're out of here holy shit yeah nominate me with marvel rival i i love marvel rival so much i even play off stream this is guys this is how much i I love Marvel Rivals,
guys.
Wait, where is it?
I almost, like, showed you guys the...
Guys, look at this.
And, like, 80% of that is off-stream.
I don't even think I've...
I don't even think I've streamed, like, 200 hours of Rivals.
Yeah, that's my...
I'm pretty sure 80% of that was me playing off-stream, too.
It wasn't even on-stream.
yeah exactly i'm having fun it means i'm having fun guys it's getting closer look at this we're halfway there we're halfway there
look if i get nominated if i get not that this is why i'm campaigning guys i don't think i'll win I just want to get nominated.
I just want to be that one VTuber in the Marble Rivals category.
That's all I want.
I just want to be that guy.
That one guy.
I don't even know.
I haven't used my alt accounts in so long.
That's the thing.
I think all my alt accounts are like, honestly, like, bronze right now.
Because I haven't touched it in that long.
I just want bragging rights to be nominated.
Yeah, I won a tournament while even playing in that tournament.
That is so true.
All the Europeans are on now because they want to do the...
I think, like, what, the Ignite games are going to start in a couple of hours.
No, I haven't touched zombies at all because I do not care about PvE.
I know it's apparently really fun, but I personally, I just don't care.
I've never...
Like, you can even say, like, what about, like, left...
for dead and stuff like that other dead is fun um i think also because i only enjoyed left for dead when it was modded i don't think i like vanilla left for dead because i think it's just you know it's just a zombie shooting game but when you mod it when you mod it and it's like like a teletub like you remember the the zombie teletubby shit and um even with friends yeah like it's the modded left for dead is so fucking fun as you have like you know you can use a base baby as a bomb was a baby wait no was the baby a med kit yeah the baby was the med kit and then I I loved picking up the babies and the whenever I remember back then like uh in the classic Lefford did Lefford did uh you can make the teletubbies as the zombies but like before they come in it'll be like uh they'll do like the teletubby song before they like slowly fucking yeah I swore um because there's like they're coming and then you just hear like tinsy-winsy mana they're like they're like they're coming po you haven't
learned it though yeah oh yeah the macho man the macho man tank yeah when you say oh yeah or the what was it the the Skyrim dragon too That shit was fucking scary as hell.
Wait, let me look.
I need to look at the Steam Workshop.
Steam Workshop.
Left-warded.
Oh, that's just like throwback, honestly.
Oh, Thomas the Tank Engine.
Oh, Thomas the...
I think my favorite mod with Thomas the Tank Engine was the Resident Evil.
The Resident Evil Thomas the Tank Engine mod with the... What's his name?
The guy in the...
The guy in the suit.
What was that guy's name?
That's fucking scary.
Mr. X.
Yeah, Mr. X has Thomas the tank engine.
That shit was fucking wild.
Leffered it.
Leffered it, too.
Most popular items in the past week of all time.
Let's see.
Wait, there's plants versus zombies?
Oh my god, and Leffered.
Wait, you can make Ellis do California.
California girls.
Oh my god, there's Minecraft song.
I think Teletubbies is the classic, though.
Teletubbies,
Which hero do you think you want to be?
I think it's Teletubbies, what is the best one out of all of them?
Alright.
Hola.
Let's see.
Soy Dora.
I swear, I don't recognize anyone at usually you know how like I play this time slot so much that like I recognize these players but um but like because like uh all the other players are like doing the watch party I was like I don't recognize anyone on my team or maybe because Celestial 3 is low as fuck I think that's why oh that's why yeah I think everyone I know is like everyone I know is I'm like,
who the fuck are these players?
I feel like I've never seen them before.
I've only...
Like, this is the first time I've seen any of these players.
No.
It's too late.
You fucked up.
If we win, maybe you'll get unbad.
If we lose, I'll sure we get your name I bet your I bet your account is linked to your discord
we're I'll ask every guess what's your discord and then I find out you're there you're out of here bro he looks like a fuck he does look like he's talking to his voices there everyone's like what the fuck is he talking to you oh I meant to said quick
unlink your discord i'll be like if you this is my requirement you want to see me at the maid cafe yeah give me your discord yeah they write down your discord and then i'll know anybody want to run anymore for a team up why is every game triple split because that's all i know
No, I'll be like, what's your Marvel Rivals account?
I'll be like, log into your, we'll have a PC there at the cafe.
I'll be like, log into your Marvel Rivals account before you can, before you can talk to Doki.
What do we got?
Bro, how do you die, bro?
Oh,
this is awkward.
enough healings for this like we do not have like it's because we don't have the team up too so that's pretty bad like if we had the team up it would be easier but we don't
can anyone else oh my god am i the only one hitting it like
Is there a reason we're on Blade or...
Why don't...
Why are we on Namur?
Why are we...
Wait, it's the AOMM agent.
Oh shit!
Wait, if you're the AOMM agent and I'm the AOMM agent...
Wait!
Let's recreate.
Oh, that's...
Yeah, forfeit
Wait a minute, who's driving this car?
All
right, I don't think we winning this though
We have to At least we broke that based on Yeah, I was gonna say it.
That's unfortunate.
I have to swap off.
Um, we originally had triple support and I've yet to die.
So like, that's not my fault.
Wait, they're triple support.
What the fuck?
What do you mean they're triple support?
That's not fair.
yes yeah we we went triple support but like that ain't fair how dare they also go triple support that should be illegal i
don't think i hit those yeah i'm still yet to die so this is very awkward for me oh my god that's all my leaves by the way
This is so bad.
This is like...
Oh my god, where?
Where is the L-enleashing?
Guys, we gotta help our magic, guys.
I was surprised I got my mantis out there.
Since I ulted first.
Guys?
Bro, I'm...
Bro!
Okay, that's fine.
I can farm this.
I'm trying my best to farm this part.
Hey, can we get that?
Like, I don't know.
Jesus Christ.
What's going on over there?
Like, who are they fighting?
They are actually fighting their inner demons right now.
Holy fuck.
I want to swap so badly.
We're like handicapped right now with our fucking heels.
Please, I've only died one time.
This is so... Are you serious?
Like, what's going on over there?
Jesus.
Oh, he has all.
Holy fuck, I knew he had all too.
Oh my god.
Please, just get him.
Get him, please.
Holy fuck out!
Okay, no ask questions.
Are you guys okay?
Like, who are you fighting right now?
I should heal him.
I tried.
I really did.
I had no leaves.
I had no leaves, guys.
Bro, look, we have too many EOMM agents, bro.
Like, I don't know what to say.
We're both EOMM agents.
I don't know what to say, man.
Oh my god, I'm so close to...
Oh my god, I finally died.
But I'm so close to...
I mean, we can still do this with my...
I think.
Please, please, please.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
That's unlucky.
I don't know if I can touch it, though.
I'm coming.
I'm touching!
All right, let's go.
Oh, I had a feeling.
It's okay.
Somehow it worked out.
Okay, now I can actually swap.
I can finally swap off.
I couldn't swap off.
I literally, it was so unfortunate.
I actually could finally swap.
Somehow it worked out.
I mean, they have.
Oh, they're not running triple support anymore.
Alright, now I can.
It was unfortunate because like we were very we were on a crutch right there with our heels But like I literally couldn't do anything because I was alive for way too long Oh you go mantis now like I mean you go like bro What do you mean you go like widow now you had I was mantis you go widow when I'm not on That is a real...
That never...
No, he wins the EOMM Agent Award.
He really does.
No, he won.
He wins.
Like, he's a better agent than me.
He really is.
That'll be fine, right?
But...
There you go.
just in case no he's actually a better agent than me I thought I was I thought I was the agent the bro is literally him time to switch things up including which side you're on I'm not the type who fades night bro who else is gonna who else is gonna play support bro no damage boost can't get played for not doing oh wait he actually swapped the club what is this oh my god people can change the agent swaps the agent give it now we can see which support is throwing more which one did guam go and send in personally
dv is sloppy
insane unheard of i know right
all right here we go
the battle starts in five yeah cheese I wish I wish Invis has a dance emote everyone deserves a dance emote like Overwatch not like every all the characters just get dance emote oh I thought he was nice
okay blow them closer where is he hello right here guys
Bro, I'm...
There's like a hella, bro.
I tried my best.
I'm so scared of that hella.
Oh, I don't have...
Maybe careful with my stuff, though.
Alright, we have a...
Oh, nice.
Oh, I think he still grabs somebody, though.
Yeah, I don't know if I can ult this.
Oh, nice.
Oh, not nice.
Only one person lived.
I feel like we have to use Cloak first.
Cloak is the better aggressor.
Yeah.
I don't know if...
I personally...
Oh, I have to use this.
Like...
Thank God for all the...
It's so...
I don't think...
I don't know.
I don't know if...
Moon Knight is the answer.
I don't think the Moon...
He said, don't worry, Moon Knight is shredding.
But I have a feeling that Moon Knight is...
May or may not be shredding.
Just maybe.
Okay.
This may be though.
You know, you know, you're always safe with me, Herbie.
He has, oh, so we gotta kill him before like anything happens.
But he's just gonna pour, oh, they're just gonna pour to this.
There you go.
Hi guys, you know what?
I did...
We get that?
Yes, we can.
That's good.
There's like a fucking Jeff behind us?
But I guess we can ignore him.
right he's fucking trying to shred my shield but that's all right i still don't think he's shredding
don't die to this jeff he died to the jeff
i'm sorry there's nothing i can do bro
I don't think there was something I could do.
I could just watch him get eaten.
That's the most fucked up part.
I just, all I could do was just watch and say goodbye.
I still don't think we're shredding.
I was promised a shred.
okay goodbye this is where they kill me
look i okay there you go he's got the kill he's ready he's doing it
all right there you go they did it
very questionable shred look i thought he was gonna win the 1v1 okay
All right You don't walk into that he's that strange all so I'm not gonna be able to push that
He's looking for it.
I can see it bro
Like I'm so no worries.
I've got your back.
Oh Oh my god, he's alive I don't know how he lives honestly that's crazy that he lived that's actually crazy there's a starlight behind there's a what behind
who's behind us
are you sure oh shit what he is what is he doing back here fucking weirdo I'm gonna help him we look for starlight don't let anything stand in here I can read it out.
Okay, I'll be here.
Oh, he wants to.
He is coming for it.
Oh, shit.
Okay, like, why?
First off, why is...
Oh, my god!
Yeah, I'm not living this.
Okay.
I did live this I did live this in the game in the in the end yeah I was like oh my god the moon is coming I don't know how he's shredded and carried he's been shredded
Heaven shot his shot.
Well, you better be coming to the Mage Cafe and ask that again.
I'll give you the answer when you're at the cafe.
Rav, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
gonna call it here guys i do have another stream later today um so yeah i'm doing batman later yeah he's not black listed from the cafe he did it he did it guys he won the game that mattered the most oh no what no the thing is i can't i got a noise complaint because of my dad so give me a sec give me a sec
okay so i'm not leaving on his terms because i got a noise complaint for the first I don't get nervous when I'm playing now.
I'm playing fucking Rivals at 6 in the morning.
I haven't gotten noise complete before I get called by my concierge.
But I hope you guys all had a fun time watching.
I always have a fun time streaming for you guys.
But yes, please, feel free to nominate me for Best Marvel Rival Streamer.
I love to be nominated.
I would love to let, you know, see myself as that one VTuber in the...
fucking crowd a flesh tuber it'll be pretty cool yeah i would really appreciate it um i'll try to do more rival streams um bonus rival streams as my campaign because i feel like it is weird if i do i feel like i don't know i have a feeling that like i should have more rival streams on twitch just because i feel like they're gonna look at my channel and then be like no you know i might get like the nominations for it And they see my channel and was like,
yeah, no.
So I need to add more streams to it to my channel.
I have the 100 hours requirement.
It was just that the 100 hours might have came from the beginning of the year.
So not a great look for me.
So I got a buff more hours.
Sue are new here.
My name is Donkey Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, so please check me out there.
We are doing a Batman stream.
We are doing a Batman stream later at 6 p.m.
PST.
But yeah, sometimes I stream on Twitch, which is right now.
And you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, feel free to follow me on Twitter, because that's where I announce my Twitch streams.
You want to support me via other means.
I have a lot of merch going on right now.
I have my Doki merch, and also the white ram the doki blade you get exclamation point like lab i think that should be the doki blade or i don't know i think i don't know if it's the blade or or collab that um that shows the doki blade oh no it's not sorry i should get rid of that i should get rid of that command because that that one um that collection's over you can't pre-order that anymore so it might be um it might just be blade right anyway thank y'all for watching I always have a great time streaming for you guys.
I'll hang out for the subs, the donations, the follows.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get on, move around, to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'm going to go back to sleep now.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye-bye.
I don't know if I'll rate anyone.
Maybe I'll just let you guys, I'll just let you guys disperse.
I can't be bothered to.
I can't be bothered right now.
I'm tired.
I'm tired now.
All right, see you guys.
Bye.
you